ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY IS SET TO
BEGIN. WE ARE MEETING TODAY IN
ROOM 2200 OF THE Þ STREET
BUILDING. WE HAVE 23 BILLS ON
THE CALENDAR. 11 BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. WE HAVE AB 1832 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO ON
CONSENT, AB 1859 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALANIS AB, 1888 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AB.
2020 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AB. 2279 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CERVANTES AB 2310 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. HART AB 2871 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. MAIENSCHEIN AB 2766 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LOH AB 3027 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BAINS AB 3042
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEPHANIE
NGUYEN AB 3168 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIBSON. IN THIS
COMMITTEE, THE AUTHOR WILL
PRESENT THEIR BILL FROM THIS
PODIUM. WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY
FROM THE MICROPHONE OUTSIDE THE
WELL, WHICH IS THAT LECTERN
RIGHT THERE. EACH BILL CAN HAVE
TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. EACH OF THOSE
WITNESSES GET TWO MINUTES EACH,
AND WE WILL TIME THEM AFTER THE
MAIN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TESTIFY, WE WILL TAKE ALL
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION METOO'S STATING THEIR
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER
THEY SUPPORT OR OPPOSE TO KEEP
HER BUSY HEARING, YOU KNOW,
GOING AND KEEPING IT SHORT, IF
YOU ARE A ME TOO, PLEASE BE
LINED UP AND READY TO GO AFTER
WE HAVE OPPOSITION THÀNH SPEAK,
WE TAKE AUTHORS AS THEY ARRIVE
IN ORDER TO BE AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE. WITH THAT, WE WILL
BEGIN. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL TO
SET QUORUM? HERE. HOBB. HERE
SATO HERE. SATO. HERE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE. SKINNER. WIENER.
ALL RIGHT. A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAN
SAWYER. FIRST, LET'S LET'S MAKE
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATOR BRADFORD HAS
MOVED. WAHAB Ã. WAHAB. AYE.
SEYARTO. SATO I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE. SKINNER. WIENER.
ALL RIGHT. THE CONSENT LIST IS
ON CALL, AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAN SAWYER
PRESENT AB 852. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS, TODAY I PRESENT
AB 852, A BILL THAT IS A
TECHNICAL CLEANUP OF MY BILL OF
AB 89 FROM 2021, FIRST, I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WORK FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL, AND I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. SECOND, I'M NOT SURE
IF I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS BEFORE, BUT I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE VICE CHAIR FOR COMING
ON AS A COAUTHOR ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. AB 89
INCREASED THE AGE REQUIREMENT
FOR PEACE OFFICERS IN THE STATE
FROM 18 TO 21 YEARS OF AGE,
FOLLOWING DATA THAT OLDER
OFFICERS ARE BETTER EQUIPPED FOR
THE JOB. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRED
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE IN MODERN
POLICING, IN ORDER TO INCREASE
THE EDUCATION REQUIREMENT FOR
GED TO AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE IN
MODERN POLICING OR ANY
BACHELOR'S DEGREE, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE RETURNED THAT
REPORT AND DEVELOPED A MODEL
CURRICULUM THAT IS NOW OUT FOR
STAKEHOLDER REVIEW. AB 852 FIXES
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS BY
CLARIFYING THE INTENT OF AB 89
TO PROVIDE A CHOICE BETWEEN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE AND A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE, AND AB 852
ALSO EXTENDS THE DEADLINE FOR
NEW RECRUITS TO HAVE TO HAVE TO
MEET THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS IN
LINE WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TIMELINES. AND ADDRESSING LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECRUITMENT CONCERNS
. LASTLY, THROUGH WORKING WITH
MY COAUTHOR, WE HAVE ADDED
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO GIVE NEW
RECRUITS UP TO 36 MONTHS AFTER
THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT. TO MEET THE DEGREE
REQUIREMENT, THIS CLEANUP BILL
WAS DEVELOPED IN COLLABORATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALIKE, WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL IS JONATHAN
FELDMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS JONATHAN FELDMAN,
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION, APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND THE VICE CHAIR IN
WORKING ON THIS WITH US AS A
CO-SPONSOR OF THE ORIGINAL BILL.
WE OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THE
ADVANCEMENT OF THE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT, BUT THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE TIME TO IMPLEMENT IT TO
AVOID ANY TYPE OF RECRUITMENT
AND ONBOARDING DEFICITS. SO WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE MEASURES IN
THE BILL. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE
ADVANCEMENT OF THE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT IN THE YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER LEAD SPEAKERS? NO. THAT'S
IT. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION? LEAD OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO ME. TWOS GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CORY SALZILLO
, ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, FOR
THE CLEANUP PURPOSES ADDRESSED.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. LIZZIE
KUTSUNA HERE. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND THE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. HI.
JUSTIN BOWERS WITH CLEAN FOR
KIDS.ORG STRONGLY SUPPORTS. IN
ADDITION, THE NCCA ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS FACTS AND
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. DAN MESNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR SERRANO, JUST JUST REAL
QUICK, I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR RECOGNIZING THAT THIS
NEEDED TO BE, WORKED ON A LITTLE
BIT, TO ADDRESS SOME
SHORTCOMINGS THAT WERE BEING
MANIFESTED IN THE HIRING PROCESS
FOR POLICE OFFICERS. OUR POLICE
OFFICERS, THEY ARE HAVING A REAL
HARD TIME WITH RECRUITMENT RIGHT
NOW. AND I THINK THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL HELP THEM AND
ALSO ACCOMPLISH WHAT THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF YOUR BILL
WAS. AND I APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH YOU ON IT AND ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE THE BEST POSSIBLE BILL
TO MOVE FORWARD. SO WITH THAT, I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SERRANO. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL?
VOTE, PLEASE. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
852. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE FLOOR. I HAVE I
SATO. SATO I BRADFORD, SKINNER.
WIENER THAT MOTION IS ON CALL OR
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. THANK YOU,
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT AB
2136 NOW, YES, I WOULD LIKE TO,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I PRESENT AB 2136 WITH
WITH CLARIFIES THE LEGALITY OF
ACCESSING AND PROVIDING DRUG
CHECKING SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ADDRESS THE PRESENCE OF FENTANYL
AND OTHER ANALOGS TAINTING THE
DRUG SUPPLY IS THROUGH EVIDENCE
BASED HEALTH AND HARM REDUCTION
APPROACHES. INCREASED ACCESS TO
NALOXONE, NALOXONE TRAINING AND
FENTANYL STRIPS HELP PREVENT
DRUG OVERDOSES AND ARE KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE AND ALIVE. DRUG
CHECKING IS SIMPLY ANOTHER
IMPORTANT TOOL AND AT OUR
DISPOSAL TODAY, RESEARCHERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
OFFERING TO ANALYZE SMALL
SAMPLES OF DRUGS TO REVEAL THEIR
COMPONENTS, INCLUDING ANY TRACES
OF FENTANYL. THEY ARE CHECKING
FOR CONTAMINATED DRUGS IN THE
AREAS IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS, LIKE MY IN MY
DISTRICT, SKID ROW IN LOS
ANGELES. BUT TECHNICALLY, THIS
SERVICE IS ILLEGAL. ALTHOUGH
DRUG CHECKING EQUIPMENT AND
TESTING ARE PERMITTED IN
CALIFORNIA TO DRUG THE DRUGS,
THE STATE'S DRUG PARAPHERNALIA
AND POSSESSION LAWS PROHIBIT
DRUG TESTING AND ANALYZING FOR
SUBSTANCE USE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
HELPING PEOPLE MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR HEALTH ARE
CURRENTLY OPERATING UNDER A
LEGAL GRAY AREA. AB 2136
ADDRESSES THE GAPS IN STATE LAW
TO ENCOURAGE MORE CITIES TO
OFFER DRUG CHECKING OR SERVICES
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS, RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS, AND STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES LEGAL,
CRIMINAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH THE DRUG
CHECKING SERVICES PROVIDERS AND
THE PARTICIPANTS. THE INTENT IS
FOR THE PROTECTION OF PROTECTION
OF AB 2136 TO APPLY ONCE THE
INDIVIDUAL IS AT THE TESTING
FACILITY. THIS IS NOT A GET OUT
OF JAIL FREE CARD. I UNDERSTAND
THIS PROVISION IS A CONCERN AND
A COMMITMENT TO WORKING ON
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE. AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. MEMBERS. IT CAN
TAKE LESS THAN TEN MINUTES TO
REVEAL VITAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THE CONTENTS OF SUBSTANCES
PEOPLE CONSUME. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE LIVES. LET'S
MAKE THAT. LET'S MAKE THAT.
LET'S NOT MAKE THAT ILLEGAL WITH
ME IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
BRENDAN HARSHBERGER WITH DRUG
CHECKING. LOS ANGELES AND GREG
GRABNER, ACTING STATE DIRECTOR
OF THE DRUG POLICY INSTITUTE AT.
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES. SAWYER, MY NAME IS GREG
GARDNER. I'M THE ACTING STATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. DPA IS A LEADING
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO END THE
DRUG WAR AND ADVANCE POLICIES
GROUNDED IN HEALTH EQUITY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS. AS WE ALL KNOW,
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE A SEVERE OVERDOSE
DEATH CRISIS. IT'S DEVASTATED
INDIVIDUALS, FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AROUND THE
STATE. THERE WERE, AGAIN ROUGHLY
12,000 OVERDOSE DEATHS IN 2023.
THIS BODY HAS TAKEN STEPS TO
RESPOND TO THIS, IN PART BY
ENSURING ACCESS TO FENTANYL TEST
STRIPS, WHICH IS A FORM OF DRUG
CHECKING. HOWEVER, FENTANYL TEST
STRIPS ALONE PROVIDE LIMITED
INFORMATION WITH AN INCREASINGLY
UNPREDICTABLE, CHANGING AND
DANGEROUS DRUG SUPPLY. THE RISK
OF ACCIDENTAL DEATH, IS EVEN
GREATER THAN EVER, EVEN FOR
CASUAL DRUG USE. DRUG CHECKING
SERVICES UTILIZE TEST STRIPS,
BUT THEY ALSO UTILIZE ADVANCED
SCIENTIFIC EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
MASS SPECTROMETRY TO PROVIDE
MORE DETAILED ANALYSIS OF THE
CHEMICAL COMPOSITION OF
SUBSTANCES, INCLUDING INDICATING
WHETHER DRUGS SUCH AS FENTANYL
OR XYLAZINE ARE PRESENT. BY
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION TO
DRUG CHECKING SERVICES, HELP
PEOPLE USE DRUGS, MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
USE. EVIDENCE HAS SHOWN THAT
WITH MORE COMPLETE INFORMATION,
PEOPLE OFTEN CHANGE THE WAY THEY
USE OR INTERACT WITH SUBSTANCE,
INCLUDING USING SLOWER, NOT
USING ALONE OR IN SOME CASES NOT
USING IT AT ALL. THESE PROGRAMS,
OFTEN PROVIDE AN ENTRY POINT TO
TREATMENT, TO MINOR MEDICAL CARE
AND PROVIDING SAFER USE OR OR
OTHER INFORMATION THAT THAT HELP
THE HEALTH OF INDIVIDUALS USING
THE SERVICES. THE RESULTS ARE
ALSO OFTEN SHARED WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO IDENTIFY
TRENDS IN THE LOCAL DRUG SUPPLY.
AB 2136 IS ABOUT HELPING ALL OF
US BETTER RESPOND TO THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. IT CLARIFIES THE
LAW THAT SUCH PROGRAMS ARE
LAWFUL AND IT PROTECTS
PARTICIPANTS AND PROVIDERS SO
THAT WE CAN LAUNCH MORE OF THESE
PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE TO
BETTER PROTECT PEOPLE. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE AND THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER, FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY. I'M CURRENTLY A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCLA AND A GRADUATE
STUDENT RESEARCHER WITH DRUG
CHECKING LÀ, AND I'VE ALSO
WORKED AS A MEDICATIONS FOR
ADDICTION TREATMENT OUTREACH
SPECIALIST AT THE LA LGBT
CENTER. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT I'M HERE TODAY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AS
AN INDIVIDUAL, BASED ON MY
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE. I BELIEVE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES TESTING.
COLLOQUIALLY, DRUG CHECKING IS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF HOW WE CAN
CURB OVERDOSE DEATHS. IN
CALIFORNIA, AB 2136 CLARIFIES
LEGALITY OF ACCESSING AND
PROVIDING DRUG CHECKING
SERVICES. PROVIDES THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS TO EXPAND THESE LIFE
SAVING SERVICES STATEWIDE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE
INFORMATION WE PROVIDE CAN
EMPOWER OUR PARTICIPANTS TO
PREVENT OVERDOSE BY CHOOSING TO
EITHER NOT USE THE SUBSTANCES WE
TEST OR TO USE THEM IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAT REDUCES HARM.
ONE SUCH LIFE SAVING SCENARIO IS
FINDING FENTANYL IN A PILL OR
POWDER THAT THE CLIENT BELIEVED
TO BE A DIFFERENT SUBSTANCE. THE
TRUST WE BUILD WITH OUR
PARTICIPANTS BY PROVIDING THEM
WITH DRUG CHECKING SERVICES HAS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT PATHWAY TO
ENGAGEMENT WITH SERVICES SUCH AS
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT AND HIV
TESTING AND TREATMENT. WHILE AT
THE L.A. LGBT CENTER, I'VE
PERSONALLY LINKED CLIENTS MET
THROUGH DRUG CHECKING TO
TREATMENT. IN ADDITION TO THE
BENEFITS AND PROTECTIONS IT
PROVIDES PARTICIPANTS, THE REAL
TIME DATA WE COLLECT ON THE
ILLICIT DRUG SUPPLY CAN INFORM
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AGENCIES RESPONSES TO EMERGING
THREATS IN THE COMMUNITY, SUCH
AS XYLAZINE, A VETERINARY
TRANQUILIZER THAT INCREASES THE
RISK OF OVERDOSE. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE THE CONFIDENCE NEEDED
FOR OUR PARTICIPANTS TO ENGAGE
IN TESTING. FOR PROVIDERS TO
START OFFERING THESE LIFE SAVING
SERVICES, AS NOW IS THE TIME TO
ADOPT THESE MEASURES. AND A
TRAGIC EXAMPLE OF TRADITIONAL
DATA ARRIVING TOO LATE. FAR TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS DIED BEFORE WE
UNDERSTOOD THE THREAT OF
COUNTERFEIT PRESSED PILLS. IT IS
MY HOPE THAT COMPREHENSIVE DRUG
CHECKING CAN HELP US GET AHEAD
OF EMERGING THREATS IN THE
ILLICIT DRUG SUPPLY AND
ULTIMATELY SAVE LIVES.
THEREFORE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION? A LEAD OPPOSITIONS
FIRST SEEING NONE ME TO. GOOD
MORNING. GLENN BECK IS DOING ME
TWOS FOR THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GEORGE FRAMPTON, ON
BEHALF OF ACLU, ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
DANICA, ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. NORMA
PALACIOS IN SUPPORT. IN ADDITION
TO DELIVERING INNOVATION IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING SAN FRANCISCO
ON DEMAND COALITION, ANY
POSITIVE CHANGE IN NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION WILL GIVE
YOU A PROJECT. AND HILLARY 360
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. HI. GOOD MORNING. I'M IDO A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF 360 AS AN AS
SALAS POLICY INSTITUTE FELLOW
AND A SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
ALSO READING SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO CAN'T BE WITH
US TODAY. AS FOR ME, TWOS,
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET OR CURB
GLIDE, LARKIN STREET YOUTH
SERVICES, SAN LUIS OBISPO
BANGERS, SYRINGE, EXCHANGE
PROGRAM, LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
MINISTER HUMAN TAMBIÉN BIENESTAR
HUMAN SERVICES. THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE, TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION,
COMMUNITY HEALTH PROJECT, LÀ AND
BALANCED, PERFECTLY BALANCED
IMPERFECTION, EXCUSE ME AND DRUG
USER HEALTH ADVOCATE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
. THANK YOU. DAN MESNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. ED
LITTLE, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER? ME TOO.
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SENATOR SATO,
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS, A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT, SO WHEN SOMEBODY
TAKES THEIR DRUG IN TO GET IT
TESTED, WHETHER IT'S IN POWDER
FORM OR PILL FORM, WHAT BECOMES
OF THE TESTED MATERIAL, IF IT IS
POSITIVE, DOES THE IS THERE A
COLLECTION PROCESS? DO THEY GET
CONFISCATED OR JUST GET GIVEN
BACK TO THEM FOR THEM TO DECIDE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO ROLL THE
DICE OR NOT? WELL, THERE
WOULDN'T BE ROLLING THE DICE
BECAUSE THEY WOULD KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT IT IS CONTAMINATED. THEY
WOULD GET IT BACK ONCE. ONCE
THEY THEY TESTED IT, ABSOLUTELY.
THEY WOULD NOT GET IT BACK IF WE
REALIZED IT HAS FENTANYL OR ANY
CONTAMINATED SUBSTANCE IN IT. SO
IT GETS CONFISCATED FROM THE
PERSON THAT'S DOING THE TESTING.
IN THE CASE WHERE THERE'S A
TESTING PLACE TO TAKE IT TO, YES
. ALL RIGHT. NOW, WOULD YOU LIKE
YOUR WITNESS TO SPEAK? SURE
BECAUSE I MAY BE SAYING
SOMETHING WRONG. SO GO AHEAD.
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY, YOU'RE
ASKING IF IT WERE TO TEST
POSITIVE FOR FENTANYL, WOULD THE
TESTING PLACE BE THE ONE TO
CONFISCATE IT OR OR I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENS TO THE DRUG
NOW THAT IT IS TESTED POSITIVE.
WHERE DOES IT GO FROM THERE, SO
IF IT IS TESTED POSITIVE, WE
PROVIDE ALL OF OUR CLIENTS BACK.
THE SAMPLE THAT WE TESTED, AND
IT WOULD BE UP TO THE CLIENT TO
DECIDE WHAT TO DO WITH IT. AT
THAT POINT. OKAY. SO WHEN I
MEANT BY ROLL THE DICE IS IF IT
DOES TEST POSITIVE FOR FENTANYL,
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO OVERDOSE
ON IT. IT MEANS WELL IN THEIR
MIND THEY MIGHT NOT OVERDOSE.
THEY'LL THINK, HEY, I'M A BIG
PERSON. I CAN TAKE THIS AMOUNT.
I'LL JUST TAKE A HALF OF IT
INSTEAD. WELL, UNFORTUNATELY,
THEY TAKE THE HALF THAT DOES
HAVE THE FENTANYL IN IT. THEN
THEY WIND UP DEAD IN THE ANYWAY,
SO, YOU KNOW, MY CONCERN WITH
BILLS LIKE THIS IS THE ENABLING
FACTOR. WE WANT PEOPLE TO GET
TREATMENT. ABSOLUTELY. THEY HAVE
TO GET TREATMENT BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO, SELF-TREAT AND GET
OFF OF DRUGS. WE DON'T WANT THEM
TO DIE FROM THIS, THIS, THIS
SCOURGE THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL EFFORTS TO
BE ABLE TO GET NOT ONLY TESTING,
BUT ALSO HAVE EVERYBODY, YOU
KNOW, IS ARMED WITH NARCAN AND
THEY RUN AROUND. AND IF SOMEBODY
GOES DOWN IN FRONT OF THEM, THEN
THEY PUT THE NARCAN IN THEM AND
HOPE THEY, THEY SPRING TO LIFE.
THOSE ARE ALL WELL AND GOOD. BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IF YOU'RE
ABUSING DRUGS, THE END RESULT IS
THAT YOU WILL MOST LIKELY, MEET
AN EARLY DEATH. AND SO WE ARE
NOT BEING COMPASSIONATE TO
PEOPLE BY BY KEEPING THEM ALIVE
NOW SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE THEIR
EARLY DEATH LATER. WHAT WE WOULD
WHAT'S COMPASSIONATE IS FOR US
TO TREAT THEM WHEN WE IDENTIFY
THAT SOMEBODY IS A DRUG ADDICT,
THAT THEY NEED TO GET TREATED.
AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
TREATMENT CENTERS, BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF DRUG ADDICTS. SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT OUR TREATMENT
CENTERS ARE VERY EFFECTIVE AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO
MAKE OUR EFFECTIVE PUSH AND
SPEND. OUR MONEY IS ENSURING
THAT TREATMENT CENTERS AND THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED THEM, GET TO
THEM AND, BECAUSE OTHERWISE
THEY'RE GOING TO DIE. THEY'RE
GOING TO DIE. I'VE HAD DRUG
ADDICTS. I'VE BEEN ON CALLS WITH
DRUG ADDICTS, AND I'LL GO ON
THEM FOR ALL YEAR. AND THEN THE
LAST CALL I GO ON IS THE ONE
WHERE THEY DIE. AND WE TRY TO
GET THEM IN AND WE TRY TO GET
THEM. IT JUST THAT'S HOW IT
WORKS. AND SO THIS IS, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK GIVES A
FALSE SENSE OF SAFETY TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE, THAT WHATEVER THEY'RE
DOING IS GOING TO BE OKAY. SO
WHEN THEY TAKE THEIR DRUG AND
THEY JUMP IN THEIR CAR AND THEY
GO CRASH INTO SOMEBODY AND DIE
THAT WAY, THAT, YOU KNOW, HEY,
AT LEAST THEY DIDN'T DIE FROM
THE DRUG OVERDOSE. SO, YOU KNOW,
I STRUGGLE WITH BILLS LIKE THIS
BECAUSE ON ONE HAND, I DO WANT
PEOPLE NOT TO OD, BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND, I DON'T WANT TO
ENABLE PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO
POTENTIALLY OD AND EVEN YOU CAN
ALSO OD ON ON DRUGS THAT ARE NOT
LACED WITH FENTANYL, SO YOU
KNOW, I DON'T THINK IT TAKES
CARE OF ALL THE PROBLEM. I TAKE
CARE OF A LITTLE BIT OF IT, BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO BE ON BOARD
WITH THIS, I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS THAT WE CAN ATTACK
THIS PROBLEM, THAT WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE. AND, AND ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE GET THE TREATMENT
THEY NEED. AND WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT. WE'RE GIVING THEM CHOICES.
WE'RE GIVING THEM BACK THE DRUG
THAT'S BAD SO THEY CAN GIVE IT
TO SOMEBODY ELSE THAT DOESN'T
HAVE THE TESTING, BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO WANT TO RECOVER
THEIR MONEY, TOO, AND GO BY THE
BY OTHER DRUGS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
LACED. SO THERE'S A LOT OF HOLES
IN THIS, AND THEY NEED TO BE
PLUGGED BEFORE I CAN JUMP ON
BOARD WITH IT. THANK YOU, ANY
OTHER MEMBERS SEEING? NONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? LOOK WHEN THEY'RE AT
THE TESTING CENTER, THERE WILL
BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO GET
DRUG TREATMENT. AND AS WE KNOW,
WE CAN'T. AND IF WE'VE TRIED TO
INCARCERATE AND FORCE PEOPLE TO
HAVE DRUG TREATMENT AND THAT
THAT DIDN'T WORK AND WE ENDED
UP, FOR EXAMPLE, IN LA COUNTY
WITH PROBABLY THE LARGEST GROUP
OF DRUG PEOPLE, DRUG DEPENDENT
IN L.A. COUNTY JAILS, FOR
EXAMPLE. AND SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE DRUG
TREATMENT CENTERS TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT THE MEMBER IS TALKING ABOUT
, BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
TREATMENT RIGHT THERE IN REAL
TIME, ONCE THEY KNOW THAT NOT
ONLY IF IT'S TAINTED OR IF IT'S
NOT TAINTED, WE'RE NOW GETTING
THEM INTO THE SERVICES OR CLOSER
TO PEOPLE WHO CAN PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES, BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT
GETTING AS MANY PEOPLE CONTACTED
WITH SERVICES AS POSSIBLE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
A MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD? CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL
VOTE, PLEASE. ITEM NUMBER TWO,
AB 2136. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WAHAB
A, WAHAB I SATO. NO. SATO. NO.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER
WIENER. THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE NUMBER 15 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES. AB 2518.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. SENATORS, TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB 2518. I FIRST WANT
TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS MEASURE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, IF AN ADULT
IS CONVICTED OF A FELONY OFFENSE
SUCH AS MURDER UPON THE RELEASE
AS A CONDITION OF THE RELEASE,
THEY ARE PROHIBITED FROM OWNING
OR POSSESSING A FIREARM FOR
LIFE. HOWEVER THE SAME CONDITION
DOES NOT APPLY TO A MINOR
CONVICTED OF THE SAME CRIME UPON
THEIR RELEASE, AS LONG AS THEY
ARE OVER 30, THEY MAY WALK INTO
A FIREARM STORE AND BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF ATTEMPTING TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM. AB 2518 IS A
COMMON SENSE AND NARROW BILL TO
SAY THAT ANY MINOR CONVICTED OF
THREE HEINOUS CRIMES MURDER OR
ATTEMPTED MURDER OR MANSLAUGHTER
IS SUBJECT TO THE SAME LIFETIME
BAN AS AN ADULT. AS NOTED IN THE
TERRIFIC ANALYSIS FOR THIS BILL,
THIS TYPE OF PROPOSED
PROHIBITION FOR A MINOR WAS
DEEMED TIMELY COMPLETED
CONSTITUTIONAL IN PEOPLE VERSUS
VILLA, WHEREIN THE COURT HELD A
JUVENILE SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT,
WERE NOT INFRINGED BY FIREARM
PROHIBITION. ACCORDING TO THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES, APPROXIMATELY
14% OF ALL VIOLENT CRIMES IN
BOTH ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WHERE I REPRESENT,
INVOLVED THE USE OF A FIREARM.
MUCH MORE MUST BE DONE TO ENSURE
CRIMINALS ARE NOT FINDING WAYS
TO CAUSE MORE TURMOIL FOR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND OUR SCHOOLS.
THIS TYPE OF POLICY PROPOSAL HAS
A VERY REAL IMPLICATION. AS A
RECENT TRAGEDY IN THE SCENARIO
HAS OCCURRED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN DECEMBER OF 2023, A FRESNO
COUNTY 14 YEAR OLD KILLED HIS
PARENTS AND ATTEMPTED TO KILL
HIS YOUNGER SISTER AS WELL. IF
AND WHEN HE IS CONVICTED OF
THESE CRIMES AT THE AGE OF 30
AND UPON RELEASE, HE WILL BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE A FIREARM. WE
CANNOT LET INDIVIDUALS LIKE HIM
OWN FIREARMS AGAIN. SENATORS, I
FIRMLY BELIEVE IN A SECOND
CHANCES. I BELIEVE PEOPLE CAN
REFORM THEMSELVES AND AFTER
THEIR INCARCERATION, GO ON TO
LIVE FULL AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER,
THERE IS NOTHING THAT SAYS A
PERSON CONVICTED OF A CRIME LIKE
MURDER NEEDS TO OWN A FIREARM TO
LIVE A PRODUCTIVE LIFE AFTER
THEY'RE RELEASED AGAIN, THIS
TYPE OF PROHIBITION ALREADY
APPLIES TO ADULTS. THERE IS NO
REASON SOMEONE WHO IS 17 AND
COMMITS MURDER SHOULD BE ABLE TO
OWN A FIREARM AGAIN, WHILE
SOMEONE WHO IS 18 WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO. THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
CHANGE IN THE LAW TO HELP REDUCE
OUR GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC. WITH
ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
ROCHELLE BEARDSLEY FROM THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DA'S OFFICE.
THIS BILL RECEIVED A UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HAS NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND YOU ONLY
HAVE ONE WITNESS? YES. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS ROCHELLE
BEARDSLEY. I'M AN ASSISTANT
CHIEF. DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY. I AM BOTH
HUMBLED AND HONORED TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2518. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORI
DAVIES FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL.
THERE IS A LOOPHOLE IN OUR
SYSTEM THAT WOULD ALLOW A PERSON
WHO HAS COMMITTED A MURDER TO
LEGALLY OWN A FIREARM. THERE HAS
BEEN A CLEAR PREFERENCE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND IN THE COURTS TO
TREAT MINORS IN JUVENILE COURT,
RATHER THAN IN ADULT CRIMINAL
COURT, EVEN WHEN THOSE CRIMES
RESULT IN TAKING SOMEONE'S LIFE,
AS IN MURDER. ONE OF THE MANY
BYPRODUCT OF THIS SHIFT IS THAT
THOSE FOUND TO HAVE COMMITTED
MURDER WOULD BE ABLE TO OWN
FIREARMS AFTER THE AGE OF 30.
THIS IS TRUE REGARDLESS OF HOW
HEINOUS AND VIOLENT THEIR CRIMES
MAY HAVE BEEN. THIS CERTAINLY
CANNOT BE THE INTENT OF SUCH A
SHIFT. THIS SHOULD BE RESOLVED.
THIS BILL DOES THAT WHEN LOOKING
AT THE PEOPLE AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL, WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
MINORS AND THEIR YOUTHFUL
INDISCRETIONS. WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT MURDERERS. THOSE FOUND
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT TO
HAVE KILLED OR ATTEMPTED TO KILL
ANOTHER HUMAN BEING. CURRENTLY,
LEGISLATION IS ALREADY IN PLACE
TO PROHIBIT FIREARMS FROM THOSE
DEEMED UNFIT AND DANGEROUS.
THAT'S APPROPRIATE AND SAFE
POLICY. THIS BILL IS NARROWLY
TAILORED TO ADDRESS THE
OWNERSHIP OF FIREARMS, BOTH BY
THOSE THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DEEMED TO BE A DANGER IN
SOCIETY. IN THE MOST EXTREME
WAY, THIS BILL IS DRAFTED IN
SUCH A WAY THAT DOES NOT HAVE A
BROAD SWEEPING EFFECT, BUT IS
FOCUSED ONLY ON THOSE CRIMES
THAT ARE A DIRECT THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. MURDER, ATTEMPTED
MURDER AND MANSLAUGHTER. THESE
ARE ALL CRIMES IN WHICH THE
PERPETRATOR HAS SHOWN A COMPLETE
DISREGARD FOR HUMAN LIFE. AS
SUCH, THAT PERSON CAN NEVER BE
TRUSTED TO OWN A FIREARM. A
FIREARM IN THE WRONG HANDS CAN
BE DEADLY, AND AB 2518 IS A STEP
TOWARDS PREVENTING THAT. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE IT. DO WE HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, DO
WE HAVE ANY ME TWOS IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE. GEORGE TH¤U ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. CHAIR
MEMBERS JONATHAN FELDMAN,
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT KRISTIN
SCHLISSEL, CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. MADAM CHAIR, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS, I'M
GOING TO MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SIERRA, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE A MOTION? I AM MOVING
THE BILL. YES. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SIERRA MOVES THE BILL.
ITEM 15, AB 2518. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATE. WAHAB.
AYE. AYE. SATO. SATO AYE.
BRADFORD. SKINNER. WIENER THAT
BILLS ON CALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LACKEY. THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT. FILE ITEM 18 AB 2645.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB 2645.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, AMBER, EBONY
AND FEATHER ALERTS ARE CRITICAL
ALERTS ASKING FOR THE PUBLIC TO
HELP US FIND ABDUCTED CHILDREN.
SINCE 2002, THESE ALERTS HAVE
BEEN ACTIVATED OVER 320 TIMES,
AND THEY HAVE INVOLVED OVER 380
VICTIMS. THEREFORE FOR THIS BILL
SEEKS TO PROVIDE ANOTHER TOOL TO
QUICKLY FIND THESE CHILDREN. AB
2645 WILL ALLOW THESE SPECIAL
ALERTS AS JUSTIFIABLE CAUSE FOR
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO SHARE
LICENSE PLATE READING DATA FROM
TOLL LANES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL, UTILIZING PLATE
READING ON TOLL LANES WOULD
ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT TO QUICKLY
IDENTIFY AND INTERCEPT KIDNAPERS
LOCATING CHILDREN IN A TIMELY
MANNER CAN BE, QUITE LITERALLY,
A LIFE SAVING DIFFERENCE. I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE NICOLE
WATERMAN, REPRESENT THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY WHO WILL BE
THE WITNESS AND MY ONLY WITNESS
FOR THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU. YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES. OKEY
DOKE, NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE, AS
DESCRIBED BY ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY.
AB 2645 WILL FACILITATE THE
SHARING OF REAL TIME LICENSE
PLATE DATA FROM TOLL LANES WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CASES OF ABDUCTIONS. AB 2645
ALLOWS TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
TO SHARE LICENSE PLATE READING
DATA, AND IT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
MORE QUICKLY FIND ABDUCTED
CHILDREN IN THESE CASES, IN
SITUATIONS LIKE AMBER ALERTS,
EVERY SECOND COUNTS. THE COUNTY
IS VERY GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLYMAN
LACKEY'S INTRODUCTION OF 2645 TO
GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO ACT QUICKLY AND
EFFECTIVELY, AND URGES THE NO
VOTE ON THE MEASURE. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, CAN I GET THE
METOO'S IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSED?
STATE YOUR NAME ORG AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS.
ROSS BUCKLEY, ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT. DENISOVSKY
WITH THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CORY SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, WOULD
YOU GUYS LIKE TO COMMENT? ALL
RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WOULD
ENCOURAGE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
AYE VOTE AND SO WOULD THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU. MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR SARAH
MOVES THE BILL. ITEM 18 AB 2645.
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. WAHAB
I HAVE I SATO I T I BRADFORD
SKINNER WIENER THAT BILLS ON
CALL. THANK YOU. CHAIR. CAN WE
SEND OUT A MESSAGE TO ALL OUR
LOVELY PRESENTERS TO SHOW UP? I
CALL IT MAKE HASTE TO THE
APPROPRIATE ROOM FOR. PERSONALLY
I SAY QUIT LOLLYGAGGING. YOU
KNOW.
I JUST NEED TO GET THIS.
OUT.
SO. HELLO. HOW ARE YOU?
NOW, IS THAT SO?
YEAH JUST. JUST.
SHE DIDN'T. YEAH SHE'S SHE'S
SHE'S A SUPPORTER, BUT SHE'S
PROBABLY WANT TO SEE. Þ. OH, YOU
MEAN, THE DIVERT THE DIVERSION?
NO. REMEMBER WHAT WE HAD TALKED
ABOUT? OH, SHE WAS LIKE. SHE WAS
. BECAUSE I WAS. LIKE, ACTUALLY.
SO I REMEMBER THAT. YEAH. SORRY
I DON'T. AND ALSO, LIKE, I
ANALYZED THIS ONE LIKE TWO WEEKS
AGO. YEAH YEAH. SO YEAH I MEAN
LET ME KNOW I MEAN, I BE NICE
TOO, IF YOU WANT ADMINISTRATIVE
SAY AS MUCH AS. YEAH YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT. YEAH.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN PRESENTING FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB 1831. ANY
TIME YOU'RE READY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WE'RE AT YOUR. YOU KNOW, WILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND SENATOR, FOR NOW.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, MADAM
CHAIR, FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TO ADD, CHAIR WAHAB
AS PRINCIPAL COAUTHOR OF THE
BILL. AND I APPRECIATE TEAMING
UP WITH YOU ON THIS EFFORT AND
ON YOURS AS WELL. AB 1831 WOULD
MODERNIZE OUR LAWS TO ENSURE
THAT AI GENERATED SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT IMAGES OF CHILDREN ARE
ILLEGAL, TO POSSESS, DISTRIBUTE
AND CREATE. WITH THE RAPID
ADVANCEMENT OF AI, THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING USED TO
CREATE HIGHLY REALISTIC IMAGES
OF CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE MATERIAL,
WHICH CAN BE VIRTUALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM A REAL
CHILD. THE CREATION OF THESE AI
GENERATED IMAGES VICTIMIZES
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN, BECAUSE
AN AI PROGRAM MUST FIRST LEARN
WHAT THESE IMAGES LOOK LIKE BY
USING REAL IMAGES OF CHILDREN
TAKEN FROM THE INTERNET, LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CATCHING PEOPLE WITH AI
GENERATED SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
IMAGES OF CHILDREN, BUT ARE NOT
ABLE TO PROSECUTE THOSE PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF CURRENT LOOPHOLES IN
OUR LAWS. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THE ABHORRENT CRIME OF
POSSESSING CREATES AND
DISTRIBUTING SEXUALLY OBSCENE
IMAGES OF CHILDREN MUST BE
ILLEGAL, NO MATTER IF IT IS AI
GENERATED OR NOT. THEREFORE,
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE ACT
QUICKLY TO STOP CHILD PREDATORS
FROM ABUSING AI TO PERPETUATE
CHILD EXPLOITATION, WE MUST
ENSURE THAT OUR LAWS ARE KEEPING
UP WITH THIS EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
TO PROTECT CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA FROM THIS ABUSE, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND I AM JOINED TODAY BY
MICKEY HØI, THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA POLICY AT COMMON
SENSE MEDIA. AND I'M ALSO JOINED
BY KAYLIN HAYMAN, WHO IS A
SURVIVOR AND VICTIM ADVOCATE
FROM VENTURA COUNTY, AND RAQUEL
KELLY, WHO PROSECUTES THESE
CASES IN VENTURA COUNTY, IS ALSO
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. OKAY. THANK YOU. SO
YOU WILL BE GRANTED TWO LEAD
WITNESSES. EACH WITNESS WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
SURE GOOD MORNING, CHAIR WAHAB
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS MICKEY HØI WITH COMMON SENSE
MEDIA, AN ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ENSURING SAFE DIGITAL
ENVIRONMENTS FOR CHILDREN. I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND TO
YOURSELF, SENATOR WAHAB, FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS CRUCIAL ISSUE.
AB 1831 ADDRESSES THE GROWING
THREAT OF AI TECHNOLOGY BEING
USED TO CREATE REALISTIC,
HARMFUL IMAGES OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE. IT MODERNIZES CURRENT LAW
TO ENSURE THAT AI GENERATED CSAM
IS ALSO ILLEGAL TO POSSESS AND
DISTRIBUTE. CREATION OF THIS AI
GENERATED CSAM COULD LEAD TO
REAL LIFE CHILDREN BEING
PHYSICALLY, MENTALLY, AND
EMOTIONALLY HARMED BY HAVING
THEIR IMAGES INCLUDED IN CSAM.
AI GENERATED CSAM PERPETUATES
THE VICTIMIZATION OF REAL
CHILDREN BY USING THEIR IMAGES
TO TRAIN AI MODELS. TO CREATE AI
GENERATED CSAM, AN AI PROGRAM
MUST FIRST FIND EXISTING IMAGES
OF REAL CHILDREN, INCLUDING CSAM
IMAGES OF REAL CHILDREN BEING
SEXUALLY ABUSED. THIS MEANS THAT
THOSE WHO GENERATE SEACM ARE
RELYING ON PRIOR VICTIMIZATION
OF ACTUAL CHILDREN, AND ARE
REVICTIMIZING THOSE CHILDREN,
WHILE VICTIMIZING OTHER CHILDREN
AS WELL. WITHOUT THIS BILL,
PEOPLE WHO POSSESS OR DISTRIBUTE
CSAM DEPICTING ACTUAL CHILDREN
MAY EVADE PROSECUTION BY
CLAIMING THOSE IMAGES THEY
POSSESS ARE AI GENERATED. RECENT
ARRESTS AND NEWS STORIES
HIGHLIGHT THE URGENCY OF
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. INSTANCES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, WHERE AI
GENERATED VIDEOS COULD BE COULD
NOT BE PROSECUTED DUE TO LEGAL
LIMITATIONS. THIS BILL ALIGNS
WITH OUR MISSION BY LEGALLY
REINFORCING THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING CHILDREN FROM HARMFUL
DIGITAL CONTENT. AB 1831 HAS
GARNERED SUPPORT FROM A WIDE
RANGE OF ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
LAW ENFORCEMENT, EDUCATIONAL
ASSOCIATIONS, AND TECH
COMPANIES. THIS BROAD SUPPORT
UNDERSCORES THE URGENT NEED FOR
AN UPDATED LEGAL FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AB 1831 IS A
PROACTIVE MEASURE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM EMERGING
TECHNOLOGICAL THREATS TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF CHILD PROTECTION BY
CLOSING EXISTING LEGAL GAPS.
SPEAKING TO THIS EXACT ISSUE
HERE TODAY, WE HAVE CAITLYN
HARMON, WHO'S GOING TO SHARE A
PERSONAL TESTIMONY. PERFECT
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CAITLIN AND I'M A 16
YEAR OLD GIRL BORN AND RAISED IN
CALIFORNIA. I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH
TO BE A SERIES REGULAR ON DISNEY
CHANNEL'S JUST ROLL WITH IT FROM
THE AGES OF 10 TO 13.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE 12 YEAR OLD
VERSION OF MYSELF BECAME A
VICTIM OF MORPHED CHILD ON JULY
16TH, 2023. THE LIVING SHIELD
PROTECTING MY INNOCENCE BROKE
WHEN I GOT A PHONE CALL FROM THE
FBI SAYING THAT A MAN WAS IN
POSSESSION OF IMAGES THAT WERE
MORPHED TO HAVE MY FACE ON
SOMEONE ELSE'S BODY,
PARTICIPATING IN SEXUAL ACTS, I
FELT VIOLATED AND DISGUSTED TO
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT GROWN
MEN SEE ME IN SUCH A HORRENDOUS
MANNER. WHILE SPEAKING ABOUT
THIS TOPIC IS DAUNTING, I KNOW
DEEP DOWN I NEED TO SHARE MY
VOICE. I NEED TO BRING AWARENESS
AND JUSTICE TO THOSE IN MY
POSITION. THIS IS NOT ONLY
AFFECTING CHILDREN IN THE PUBLIC
EYE, BUT ALSO NORMAL KIDS SIMPLY
EXISTING. THESE CASES AFFECT
ONE'S SOCIAL LIFE AS WELL AS
BEING DETRIMENTAL TO MENTAL
HEALTH. IT TRULY GIVES THE
FEELING OF BEING ALONE. BUT TO
ALL OTHER VICTIMS, I AM LIVING
PROOF THAT YOU ARE NOT ALONE.
SINCE MY VICTIMIZATION, IT IS A
CONSTANT THOUGHT THAT EVERY MAN
HAS MALICIOUS INTENT AGAINST ME
BECAUSE I FEEL A LACK OF
PROTECTION IN MY EVERYDAY LIFE.
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE MADE ME
FEEL UNEASY AND ANGRY. THE FACT
THAT GROWN ADULTS THINK THAT
THIS IS RIGHT IS APPALLING. IT
IS EVEN WORSE THAT THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE SETTING EXAMPLES FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN. THE CHILDREN
GROWING UP IN TODAY'S WORLD ARE
BEING EXPOSED TO HARMFUL
MATERIAL, BUT THAT CAN BE
STOPPED. THERE IS DEVELOPMENT
GOING IN A NEGATIVE DIRECTION,
BUT WE CAN STILL CHANGE THE
ENDING. NOT ONLY IS THIS GOING
TO HELP CHILDREN ALL OVER THE
WORLD, BUT IT WILL PROTECT THEIR
INNER PEACE AND INNOCENCE.
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE WITH SO
MUCH POWER, AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY ARISING FOR POSITIVE
GROWTH. THIS STATE IS ALSO HOME
TO THE BASE OF THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. THIS LAW WOULD PROTECT
MINORS IN THE INDUSTRY FROM
BEING SEXUALLY EXPLOITED LIKE
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR DECADES. NO
MORE KIDS WOULD HAVE TO BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE FEELING THAT
THEY WERE NOT PROTECTED,
RESPECTFUL. I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT AB 1831. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, CAN WE
HAVE METOOS IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION? GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, KIM STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MATT
BRAUDE HERE ON BEHALF OF
SAG-AFTRA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, LIZZIE KUTSUNA
HERE ON BEHALF OF TECHNET AND
L.A. CITY ATTORNEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN
SUPPORT GARETH ELLIOTT ON BEHALF
OF MICROSOFT, IN SUPPORT. RAQUEL
KELLY ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY ERIC
NAZARENKO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KRISTIN SCHLUSSEL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT GEORGE
TH¤U ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE HAVE AN
OPPOSING, LESS AMENDED POSITION,
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR IS
WILLING TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS, SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CORY SALZILLO, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS,
I'M GOING TO TURN IT BACK TO
MYSELF. SO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I
DO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOUR WITNESS
FOR SHARING HER STORY. IT MEANS
A LOT TO JUST HEAR AS TO EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON. I WILL ALSO
STATE THAT FOR ME AS CHAIR, I
THINK THAT THE CRIMES, ANY TYPE
OF SEXUALLY VIOLENT CRIMES OR
CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN I TAKE
VERY SERIOUSLY, SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING YOUR
STORY. I THINK THIS IS THE
REASON WHY WE'VE SEEN SO MANY
BILLS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
KIND OF, COME OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
DIED IN THIS COMMITTEE, SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS. I
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP AS
WELL. I'LL ASK YOU TO CLOSE.
YEAH. I JUST REALLY APPRECIATE
WORKING TOGETHER WITH YOU AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR TEAM FOR, YOU
KNOW, ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING ON THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
I WANT TO THANK BOTH MY
WITNESSES FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EVERYONE'S AYE VOTES WHEN THEY
GET HERE. THANK YOU. AND I
CANNOT MAKE A MOTION. THAT'S ONE
OF THE RULES. SO I WILL HAVE TO
WAIT. SO ON THIS ONE, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
MOTION. THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT I'M GOING TO ASK
FOR OUR SENATE SERGEANTS TO MAKE
CALLS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANCHEZ
TING SORIA AND MAIENSCHEIN AND
KALRA TO SHOW UP, OTHERWISE, WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON, IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 1877. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AB 1877
IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT OUR YOUTH
CAN THRIVE AND THAT THEIR PAST
MISTAKES WILL NOT BE HAUNTED,
HAUNTING THEIR FUTURE. IN BRIEF,
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE A COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICER TO PETITION A
COURT TO SEAL THE RECORDS OF ANY
PERSON PREVIOUSLY ADJUDICATED A
WARD OF THE COURT WHO HAS
REACHED THE AGE OF 18 AND WHO IS
NO LONGER UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF THE JUVENILE COURT AT THIS
POINT. CURRENT LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS THE PERSON WHO'S BECOME
AN ADULT TO ACTUALLY PETITION
THE COURT. BUT AS YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES THESE ARE LONG AND
COMPLICATED PROCESSES, AND SO
THERE IS NO REASON WHY THE STATE
CANNOT DO IT THEMSELVES SO THAT
THEY CAN HAVE A FRESH START,
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES? I DO
NOT PERFECT, DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE. CAN WE GET ME TWO'S
NATASHA MINSKER SMART. JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
DANICA ADAMO ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND SUPPORT
ANNIE THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. AND SUPPORT AND
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT. LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY AND THE SENATE-TV
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. DAN
MESNER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT GEORGE
TH¤U ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JIM LINDBERG, FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS,
I'M GOING TO MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
SCHROEDER, THANK YOU. AND I'M
SORRY MISSED THE FULL REPORT
THERE, WE'RE TRYING TO JUGGLE
COMMITTEES HERE. AS YOU KNOW,
ONE THING I WANTED TO CLARIFY,
WE ALREADY WE ARE ABLE TO SEAL
RECORDS FROM JUVENILE AND YOUR
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THEM TO
DESTROY THE RECORDS OF A
JUVENILE, NO, IT JUST SAYS TO
SEAL THE RECORDS. RIGHT. WE
ALREADY SEAL THE RECORDS. WELL
NO, NOT AUTOMATICALLY. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
MEANING IF A PERSON WHO WAS A
JUVENILE AND HAS A RECORD WHEN
THEY TURN 18, THEY THEMSELVES
CAN GO THROUGH A LEGAL PROCESS
MÁS TO BE ABLE TO SEAL THEIR
RECORDS. THIS ONE DOES IT
AUTOMATICALLY. AND THAT THE I
THINK THAT PROCESS IS THERE SO
THAT WE, DETERM NGUYEN, WHEN
IT'S BENEFICIAL TO SEAL A RECORD
AND WHEN IT MIGHT BE BENEFICIAL
TO LOOK BACK ON A RECORD TO SEE
IF THERE WAS A PATTERN THAT IS
BEING CONTINUED AS AN ADULT, AND
, AND, AND THEN THAT KIND OF
GIVES YOU A BETTER IDEA OF
WHETHER THEY'VE GOTTEN PAST,
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING AS AN ADULT, THEN
NOBODY NEEDS TO GO BACK ON AND
LOOK AT THE RECORD. BUT ONCE
THEY STARTED PERPETRATING OTHER
CRIMES AS AN ADULT, THEN THEY
WILL REFER BACK TO THE SEALED.
YEAH. THIS ONE DOES NOT PRECLUDE
ALL SEAL RECORDS, ONLY IT
PRECLUDES ONLY THOSE THAT ARE,
MORE EGREGIOUS, THE ISSUE IS,
AND WE THERE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF COUNTS THAT WHEN A YOUNG
PERSON IS TRYING TO OBTAIN THEIR
FIRST JOB OR TO GET A JOB THAT
HAS MORE MEANINGFUL, WAGES,
THAT, IN FACT, WHEN THEY ARE
STILL HAVING TO, CHECK OFF THAT
BOX, WHETHER THEY HAVE A
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND HISTORY THAT
IS PRECLUDING A LOT OF YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM GETTING THE TYPE OF
EMPLOYMENT NECESSARY TO PREVENT
THEM FROM EVER EVEN CONSIDERING,
GOING BACK TO ANY OF THOSE
CRIMES IN THE PAST. AND SO WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO HAVE A
FRESH START, AND THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
ON A PATH TO THRIVE. YEAH, I
THINK FRESH STARTS ARE GREAT.
AND I THINK THEY ARE PERPETUATED
OR THEY'RE, THEY'RE I GUESS THEY
ARE PERPETUATED WHEN A PERSON
DECIDES THAT THEY ARE NO LONGER
GOING TO ENGAGE IN IN THE
ACTIVITY THAT GOT THEM THAT,
THAT, THAT RECORD IN THE FIRST
PLACE, AND BUT I ALSO THINK
PEOPLE, IN CERTAIN EMPLOYEES,
THEY NEED TO KNOW ALSO, WHAT THE
BACKGROUND IS, A LOT OF THEM ARE
FINE WITH IT, AND THEY'RE FINE
HELPING THE PERSON ALONG, BUT
FOR THEM NOT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION ONLY TO FIND
OUT SECONDHAND, AND THEN THAT
BECOMES THE PROBLEM. AND THE
THING I JUST THINK THAT I THINK
WE HAVE THE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
THAT WE NEED, AND, AND FOR BOTH
THE PERSON THAT DID THE HAD THE
RECORD AND THE PERSON'S THAT
MIGHT HIRE THEM OR, OR ELSE. SO,
ANYWAY, I'M NOT GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY. I
THINK WE ALREADY HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS PLACED. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER. AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT. I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO LEAVE TO PRESENT. I
WILL HAVE SENATOR SATO TAKE OVER
AS VICE CHAIR. AND, WE'RE GOING
TO HOPEFULLY LIFT THE CALL AND
ASK FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO PRESENT.
SO, SENATOR SKINNER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CONTINUE, YES. THANKS SO
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I WILL
MOVE YOUR BILL. I'M VERY PLEASED
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING IT, THE
PROCESS YOU DESCRIBED THAT A
PERSON HAS TO GO THROUGH TO GET
THEIR RECORD SEALED WHEN IT WHEN
EVEN THOUGH WE OBVIOUSLY ALLOW
FOR IT, IS COSTLY AND TIME
CONSUMING, AND SOME PEOPLE JUST
DO NOT HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL, THE
RESOURCES OR OTHER AVAILABLE TO
THEM TO GO THROUGH THAT, AND
THEN THIS THING BECOMES A LIKE
AN ALBATROSS AROUND THEIR NECK,
WHICH IF THEY HAVE, COMPLETE
SEATED WHATEVER, REQUIREMENTS
WE'VE PUT ON THEM FOR THEIR FOR
THE ACTIVITY THAT PUT THEM IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AND THEY ARE
THEN, AS YOU'VE CONSTRUCTED IT,
IT IS THEIR PROBATION OFFICER
THAT DOES THIS, THEN I THINK IT
IS ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE AND
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PRESERVING OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
WITH THAT, I MOVE YOUR BILL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION, YOU MAY CLOSE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. SO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR IS
ON THIS ONE, BUT, GO AHEAD AND
CALL. ROLL ITEM SEVEN. MOTION IS
Dð. I'M SORRY. ITEM SEVEN, AB
1877. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATE. WAHAB SATO. NO.
SATO. NO. BRADFORD SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP, WE HAVE AB
1874 BY SANCHEZ. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WELCOME YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 1874 TODAY, WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE JUDGES MORE
DISCRETION IN ISSUING PENALTIES
FOR CONVICTED CRIMINALS WHO
REPEATEDLY RECORD MINORS IN
INTIMATE SETTINGS WITH SEXUAL
INTENT. AS THE MOTHER OF A YOUNG
CHILD, I CAN TELL YOU NOTHING IS
MORE IMPORTANT TO PARENTS THAN
THE SAFETY OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
MY HEART SINKS WHEN I HEAR ABOUT
THE CASES INVOLVING YOUNG
CHILDREN BEING SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED AND SECRETLY RECORDED
BY VILE PEOPLE WHO KNOW THAT
THEY ARE HURTING CHILDREN, THERE
ARE FEW THINGS MORE PRECIOUS
THAN A CHILD'S INNOCENCE, AND
WHEN THEY ARE A VICTIM OF THIS
CRIME, THEY ARE ROBBED OF THAT
INNOCENCE. THAT'S WHY I WAS
SHOCKED WHEN THE ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT CAME TO ME
TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE, AND HOW
REPEAT OFFENDERS ARE CONTINUING
TO VICTIMIZE CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THE PENALTY FOR
SECRETLY RECORDING A MINOR IN AN
INTIMATE SETTING IS A FINE. NO
MORE THAN $2,000 OR LESS THAN A
YEAR IN COUNTY JAIL. THE
PUNISHMENT FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL,
IF THEY DO IT A SECOND TIME, IS
THE SAME. THE PUNISHMENT IF THEY
DO IT A THIRD, FOURTH OR FIFTH
TIME IS THE SAME. TO ME. THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE. THAT'S WHY I
INTRODUCED AB 1874 TO ENSURE
THAT REPEAT OFFENSE OF RECORDING
MINORS IN INTIMATE SETTINGS IS
TREATED SERIOUSLY, AND THAT
JUDGES HAVE ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO
BETTER SECURE OUR COMMUNITIES
AND REHABILITATE THESE
CRIMINALS. THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH THAT STRIKES A
FAIR BALANCE BETWEEN ENSURING
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND
REHABILITATING REPEAT OFFENDERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE AND
TESTIFYING WITH ME TODAY IS
CAPTAIN RACHEL PAQUETTE WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. YES, SIR.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS CAPTAIN RACHEL PUCKETT. AS
THE CAPTAIN OF THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS BUREAU AT THE
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT, I OVERSEE A STELLAR
TEAM OF OVER 60 PROFESSIONALS
WHO HANDLE COMPLEX AND SENSITIVE
CASES RANGING FROM CYBER CRIMES
TO HOMICIDE, AND CASES WHERE
CHILDREN ARE THE VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. IT IS MY HONOR
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT
ASSEMBLY BILL 1874, AS PROPOSED
BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN SANCHEZ. WE ARE
SO APPRECIATIVE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANCHEZ HAS SHED LIGHT ON
THIS NEEDED CHANGE. THE CURRENT
LAW MAKES IT A MISDEMEANOR TO
SECRETLY RECORD ANOTHER
IDENTIFIABLE AND IDENTIFIABLE
PERSON WHO MAY BE IN A STATE OF
FULL OR PARTIAL UNDRESS IN AN
AREA WHERE A PERSON HAS A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY. CURRENTLY, THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
THOSE WHO REPEATEDLY COMMIT THIS
CRIME, IN MY OPINION AND
EXPERIENCE IS APPALLING AND
UNACCEPTABLE. ALMOST ALL ASPECTS
OF THE PENAL CODE HAVE CARVED
OUT CARVE OUTS FOR MINORS, AND
HAVE GREATER PENALTIES FOR SUCH,
WHICH ACKNOWLEDGES THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE MORE VULNERABLE OR
MORE EASILY EXPLOITED AND
ULTIMATELY SUFFER EVEN GREATER,
IRREPARABLE MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL
HARM. BECAUSE OF CHILDHOOD
VICTIMIZATION. WE BELIEVE AB
1874 WILL FIX THIS PROBLEM. AB
1874 WOULD ALLOW A PERSON
CONVICTED OF A SEX A SECOND OR
SUBSEQUENT OFFENSE OF PC. 647
JULIET THREE TO FACE FELONY
PUNISHMENT. WE STRONGLY FEEL
THAT AN INCREASE IN PUNISHMENT
FOR A SECOND OR SUBSEQUENT
OFFENSE WOULD ACT AS A DETERRENT
, AND SUFFICIENT JUSTICE FOR
VICTIMS WOULD BE ACHIEVED. AS
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPS AND DEVICES
TO RECORD BECOME EASIER TO
CONCEAL, IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE LAW RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT TO
THOSE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF BEING
SECRETLY RECORDED. ONE CASE THAT
DEFINITELY I WOULD LIKE TO BRING
AS AN EXAMPLE IS A CASE THAT WE
HAD IN ORANGE COUNTY, WHERE A 60
YEAR OLD MAN WAS CAUGHT IN 2023
WITH OVER 500 VIDEOS FOUND ON
HIS PHONE. THE SUSPECT HAD THREE
SIMILAR ARRESTS OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS FOR SIMILAR CONDUCT.
HAD THE PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW
BEEN IN PLACE, THERE IS A
LIKELIHOOD HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
SERVING A SENTENCE PREVENTING
HIM FROM COMMITTING THIS
OFFENSE. OUR CHILDREN ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE AND WE
MUST PROTECT THEM, ADVANCE IN
TECHNOLOGY HAVE MADE IT MUCH
EASIER TO MANIPULATE PHOTOS. YOU
WRAP UP, PLEASE. YES SIR. SEND
THEM TO OTHERS OR POST THEM ON
INTERNET SITES. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS,
AND SEND A STRONG MESSAGE TO
THOSE WHO VICTIMIZE OTHERS AND
VIOLATE ONE'S PRIVACY THAT THEY
WILL BE MET WITH CONSEQUENCE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO BE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS? AND THEY CAN HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO EXPRESS THAT? IF NOT,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE METOOS
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU ARE IN
FAVOR OR AGAINST THIS BILL,
PLEASE COME TO THE MIC, STATE
YOUR OBJECTION OR SUPPORT AND
WHO YOU ARE AND WHERE YOU'RE
FROM. MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS CORY
SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KRISTEN SCHLUSSEL, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT GEORGE TH¤U ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, RICHARD
MAHER, AMERICA FIRST POLICY
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK? AGAIN, NO
QUESTIONS. CONCERNS, COMMENTS.
NOBODY. OKAY OKAY. WELL NO. ALL
RIGHT. I WILL SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING A BILL LIKE THIS, I
KNOW THERE'S SENTIMENT OUT THERE
THAT, YOU KNOW, INCREASING, THE
PENALTIES DOES NOT REDUCE CRIME,
BUT, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT ABOUT AT THE REDUCTION IN
CRIME AS MUCH AS IT IS ABOUT
SEPARATING THE PEOPLE COMMITTING
THOSE CRIMES FROM THE PEOPLE
THEY ARE VICTIMIZING. AND THEN
UNTIL WE FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
WITH THEM. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TYPE OF BILLS, THIS IS AN
EGREGIOUS, EGREGIOUS, ACT THAT,
PEOPLE DO AND THEY DON'T DO IT
BY ACCIDENT. THIS IS THEY'RE
DOING IT ON PURPOSE. AND, AND SO
THIS IS A WAY FOR US TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE, AND AT THE
SAME TIME, SEPARATE THOSE THEM
FROM DOING THE ACTIVITY, THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO DO. AND, AND I
THINK THIS IS A WAY OF HANDLING
IT. AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD WAY
OF HANDLING IT. SO WITH THAT, I
WILL, ENTERTAIN. I MEAN, YOU CAN
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE. I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, AB 1874 IS A
REASONABLE MEASURE THAT WILL
PROVIDE JUDGES MORE DISCRETION
TO PUNISH CONVICTED CRIMINALS
WHO REPEATEDLY RECORD MINORS IN
INTIMATE SETTINGS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND SINCE I
AM NOT ABLE TO. CAN I GET A
MOTION? I'M ABOUT TO SEND THE
GAVEL DOWN THERE. YEAH WE'LL
JUST WAIT. I'LL JUST WAIT. WE'LL
JUST WAIT. AND, ALL RIGHT, LET'S
DO IT THAT WAY. I AM NO LONGER
THE CHAIR FOR RIGHT NOW. I
SENATOR SALATA, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE A MOTION? I THINK I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. I'D LIKE TO. THIS
MOTION TO GO FORWARD, THIS BILL
TO GO FORWARD. THANK YOU, THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED, CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB
1874. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATE. WAHAB SEYARTO. AYE.
SATO I BRADFORD SKINNER. WIENER
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. OKAY. GREAT OKAY. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. YOU
MAY PRESENT. AND WOULD YOU LIKE.
YES PLEASE. THANK YOU. JUST IN
CASE YOU HAVE TO GO TO ENERGY.
THAT'S TRUE. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BOTH. MADAM AND MR.
CHAIR, UNDER CURRENT LAW, PENAL
CODE SECTION 29805 PRESCRIBES A
NUMBER OF MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES
THAT UPON CONVICTION, PROHIBIT A
PERSON FROM POSSESSING A FIREARM
ARM FOR A PERIOD OF TEN YEARS.
SOME OF THESE OFFENSES,
INCLUDING THREATENING PUBLIC
OFFICIALS, ASSAULT, AND CHILD
ABUSE. HOWEVER, IF A DEFENDANT
IS CHARGED WITH ONE OF THESE
CRIMES AND IS GRANTED
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION, THERE IS
NO BAN ON FIREARM POSSESSION. AB
2519 PROHIBITS A DEFENDANT WHO
RECEIVES MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION
FOR A CRIME LISTED IN PENAL CODE
SECTION TWO 905 FROM POSSESSING
A FIREARM UNTIL THEY HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED DIVERSION
. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. DID YOU
BRING ANY WITNESSES WITH YOU
TODAY? NO OKAY, IS THERE ANYBODY
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL?
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK AS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? IS
THERE ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE AND BE A ME TO
JUST STATE YOUR SIMPLE, SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL ON
ARCHIMEDES WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KRISTEN SCHLUSSEL, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. VERY
GOOD AND THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
BE ANYBODY ELSE, SO AT THIS
TIME, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS FOR ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS
? I WILL MOVE THE BILL. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED. MR. OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
WITH THAT, WE REQUEST, I MEAN,
WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER. GO AHEAD AND
CALL ROLL ITEM NUMBER 16, AB
2519. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB SATO I
SATO, I BRADFORD SKINNER.
SKINNER I WIENER BELLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL.
WE HAVE NO OTHER. LET'S GO AHEAD
AND ADD ON. WE'VE GOT IT. OH WE
DO. OH, MISS SORIA, THERE YOU
ARE. SORRY YES. YOU KNOW, COME
ON UP. AND, YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL AT THIS TIME. GREAT. GOOD
MORNING, MR. VICE CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, AB 2281 IS A SIMPLE BUT
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR OUR
TRIBAL JUDGES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO SIMILAR TO OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS, TRIBAL
COURTS OVERSEE A VARIETY OF
LEGAL CASES THAT CAN TOUCH UPON
VERY SENSITIVE ISSUES,
MISDEMEANOR CASES, CUSTODY
BATTLES AND CHILD SUPPORT CASES
RISKED THE CHANCE OF EMOTIONS
BECOMING HEIGHTENED AND LEADING
TO THREATS AND ASSAULTS ON
TRIBAL COURT JUDGES. A 2022
STUDY PUBLISHED BY THE CENTER
FOR JUDICIAL EXECUTIVE SECURITY
NOTES THAT THE RATE OF THREATS
AND COURT HOUSE VIOLENCE HAS
INCREASED EVERY DECADE IN THE
UNITED STATES BETWEEN 1970 AND
2010. IN AN EFFORT TO GUARD
AGAINST SUCH INCIDENTS, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA GRANTS
ADDITIONAL SAFETY AND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS TO STATE AND FEDERAL
JUDGES. HOWEVER, EVEN THOUGH
TRIBAL COURT JUDGES OFTEN FACE
SIMILAR THREATS OF VIOLENCE IN
COURTROOMS, THEY ARE EXCLUDED
FROM THESE SAFETY AND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. AB 2281 EXPANDS
EXISTING LEGAL PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT TRIBAL COURT JUDGES
ARE AN EQUAL STANDING WITH THEIR
STATE AND FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2122 8081 IS
HEATHER HOLSTER, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN LEGAL SERVICES, SO MY
SAMANTHA CYPRET, CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR CHAIRMAN TARANGO OF WILTON
RANCHERIA. ALL RIGHT, WHICHEVER
WISHES TO SPEAK FIRST, YOU MAY
COME UP TO THE MIC. EACH OF YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. IF YOU COULD
REMAIN. I MEAN, STAY CLOSE TO
ACTUALLY, OUR SECOND WITNESS IS
STILL ON THE WAY WALKING. OH,
I'M SORRY. YEAH. PARKING IS
TOUGH TODAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. GO AHEAD AND BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2281. MY NAME IS
HEATHER HOSSLER. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
INDIAN LEGAL SERVICES AND A
CITIZEN OF THE HOOPA VALLEY
TRIBE. THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
LEGAL SERVICES WAS ESTABLISHED
IN 1967 DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ERA, TO ADVANCE AMERICAN INDIAN
RIGHTS, SELF-DETERMINATION AND
TRIBAL NATION BUILDING SKILLS.
AS GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL COURT JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND HAS A BIRD'S EYE
VIEW OF MANY OF THE ISSUES AND
BROUGHT FORWARD THIS BILL IN
RESPONSE. AB 2281 SEEKS TO
EXTEND CRUCIAL PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS TO TRIBAL COURT
JUDGES OF FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
INDIAN TRIBES. THIS BILL IS NOT
JUST ABOUT EXTENDING PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. IT IS ABOUT
RECOGNIZING AND RECTIFYING THE
INEQUITIES TRIBAL FACED BY
TRIBAL COURT JUDGES. IT
ACKNOWLEDGES THEIR ESSENTIAL
ROLE IN UPHOLDING THE RIGHTS AND
SOVEREIGNTY OF FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES, AND ENSURES
THAT THEY PERFORM THEIR DUTIES
WITHOUT FEAR OF THEIR PERSONAL
SAFETY. IN RECENT YEARS, THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
DEMONSTRATED A STRONG COMMITMENT
TO SOCIAL AND RACIAL JUSTICE,
PASSING SIGNIFICANT REFORMS TO
ADDRESS SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES WE
ARE ASKING THAT YOU ADDRESS YET
ANOTHER DISPARITY THROUGH AB
2281 AND ENSURE THAT TRIBAL
COURT JUDGES RECEIVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF PROTECTION AND RESPECT
AS THEIR PEERS IN THE STATE AND
FEDERAL JUDICIARY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
PLEASE THANK YOU. SOPHIA. NICKI
KHAN, MY NAME IS SAMANTHA CYPRET
AND I AM MOUNTAIN MIGHTY FROM
THE TAYLORSVILLE RANCHERIA.
HELLO AND GOOD MORNING TO CHAIR
MCCARTY AND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. I AM I SERVE AS THE
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR WILTON
RANCHERIA. I ALSO TEACH FEDERAL
INDIAN LAW AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PACIFIC'S MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF
LAW. I PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS THE
TRIBE'S TRIBAL COURT DIRECTOR,
AND IT'S WITH THAT CAPACITY THAT
I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
2281 22 AB 2281 WOULD AFFORD
TRIBAL COURT JUDGES THE SAME
LEVEL OF PROTECTION GRANTED TO
STATE AND FEDERAL COURT
OFFICERS. AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
WORKED IN BOTH STATE AND TRIBAL
COURTS, I KNOW THIS LEGISLATION
IS CRUCIAL FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
FIRST, TRIBAL COURT JUDGES ARE
OFTEN TASKED WITH MAKING
DECISIONS AND HIGHLY CONTENTIOUS
AND EMOTIONALLY CHARGED MATTERS
SUCH AS GUARDIANSHIPS PROTECT
ORDERS AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HEARINGS. AND WHILE EACH TRIBE
MAY BE DIFFERENT, MANY TRIBAL
COURTS DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
BASIC LEVEL OF SECURITY, SUCH AS
BAILIFFS AND METAL DETECTORS
CONSIDERED COMMONPLACE IN STATE
AND FEDERAL COURTS. MANY TRIBES
HAVE NO SECURITY MEASURES IN
PLACE AT ALL. THIS WHEN COUPLED
WITH THE FACT THAT MANY TRIBES
ARE IN VERY RURAL OR REMOTE
AREAS, CAN LEAD TO TRAGEDY.
WE'VE SEEN CATASTROPHIC EXAMPLES
OF THIS, OF THIS COMBINATION
SPECIFICALLY THE HEARTBREAKING
EVENTS AT THE CEDARVILLE
RANCHERIA IN 2014 WHERE FOUR
PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND OTHERS
WOUNDED IN THE MIDDLE OF A
TRIBAL PROCEEDING. NEXT, TRIBAL
COURT JUDGES MAY BE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY WORK
. THIS CAN PUT THEM IN INCREASED
RISK FOR ASSAULT OR OTHER
THREATS OF VIOLENCE OUTSIDE OF
THE COURTROOM, OFFERING TRIBAL
COURT JUDGES THE SAME LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIALITY AS STATE AND
FEDERAL JUDGES WOULD ALLOW FOR
INCREASED PROTECTION AND PEACE
OF MIND AS THEY SERVE THEIR
NATION'S. FINALLY, TRIBAL COURT
JUDGES DESERVE THE SAME DIGNITY
AND RESPECT AS FEDERAL COURTS.
THIS THIS BILL WOULD AFFIRM THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
RECOGNIZING AND PRESERVING
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY. THIS
LEGISLATION CONFIRMS THAT TRIBAL
NATIONS, BY WAY OF THEIR
JUDICIARY, ARE DESERVING OF THE
SAME APPRECIATION, RESPECT AND
SECURITY AS ANY OTHER GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
AB 2281 IS NOT JUST A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. IT IS A
NECESSARY ACTION TO CORRECT THE
CURRENT DISPARITY BETWEEN TRIBAL
COURT JUDGES AND STATE AND
FEDERAL JUDGES. THE PROTECTIONS
OUTLINED IN THIS LEGISLATION ARE
CRUCIAL AND IMPORTANT. THANK
YOU. YOUR TWO MINUTES IS UP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING. DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
AS A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS? IF
NOT, WE WILL TAKE THE METOOS AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND STATE YOUR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT,
WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR APPROVE OF
THE BILL. MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS
CORY SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ANYBODY ELSE
IS COMING UP. SO AT THIS TIME,
WE'LL BRING IT UP TO THE DAIS.
ANY QUESTIONS? A MOTION.
SKINNER. I WILL MOVE THE BILL,
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SORIA. YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH. THANK YOU, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I DO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND FOR THE
RECORD, IT IS CHAIRWOMAN WAHAB,
I KNOW THAT THE ONE OF MY. OH, I
THOUGHT YOU WERE REFERRING TO
ME. NO, I AM NOT. SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I JUST KNOW,
WE GET WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
ALL RIGHT. AND SO ANYWAY, SO
JUST BEFORE WE TAKE THE ROLL.
YES, MA'AM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT. THIS
IS A. THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
AFFORDED TO OUR TRIBAL JUDGES.
SO YOU'RE JUST MAKING SOMETHING,
EQUITABLE BECAUSE THEY PLAY THE
SAME ROLE IN THE SAME ROLE IN
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM FOR OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES, AS OUR
JUDGES DO FOR THE REST OF US. SO
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE IT. ALL
RIGHT. AND WAS YOUR CLOSING
FINISHED? I DIDN'T YES OKAY.
VERY GOOD. THANK YOU. SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION, GO AHEAD AND
CALL. ROLL FOR ITEM 81. MOTION
TO DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WAHAB SEYARTO I, I BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL WILL REMAIN
ON CALL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
AND NEXT UP, WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING. I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
TWO BILLS TO PRESENT. I DO THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. IF I COULD
PROCEED WITH AB 2178, LET'S
PROCEED WITH AB 2178. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. SO AB 2178 IS A
STRUCTURED APPROACH TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S EMPTY PRISON BED
ISSUE IN OUR FACILITIES. WITH
THE LOOMING BUDGET DEFICIT.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NUMEROUS BEDS,
OVER 13,000 BEDS AND PROJECTED
TO HAVE ALMOST 20,000 EMPTY BEDS
BY 2028, THIS OBVIOUSLY HAS
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL COSTS TO OUR
STATE, IT SEEMS TO BE FISCALLY
PRUDENT TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
REDUCE OUR EMPTY BED CAPACITY
OVER TIME. THIS BILL MERELY
TELLS THE DEPARTMENT TO REDUCE
THE PRISON BED THRESHOLD FROM
ITS CURRENT 13,000 BED
THRESHOLD. OVER TIME. TO 29 TO
2930, TO HAVE A 2500 BED
CUSHION. WE THINK THIS IS VERY
PRUDENT, IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE. AND ALSO IS IT GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT PLENTY OF TIME TO
RAMP DOWN THE NUMBER OF EMPTY
BEDS IN THEIR FACILITIES AND
GIVEN OUR FISCAL SITUATION, IT'S
ONE OF THE ONE AREAS WHERE WE
COULD CUT IN OUR BUDGET. SO WITH
THAT, I DO HAVE LEO HERE. IF
THERE'S ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
WITH THAT RESPECT FOR VIOLA. ALL
RIGHT. ARE YOU HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OR TO I'M
YOUR SUBSTANTIVE WITNESS. SORRY
MY WITNESS. OKAY, SO, YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. IF YOU WOULD,
PLEASE KEEP TO THAT. NATASHA
MINSKER FOR SMART JUSTICE,
CALIFORNIA, AS THE SENATORS WELL
KNOW, THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET DEFICIT
. WE ARE FACING POTENTIAL CUTS
IN EDUCATION, PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CRITICAL SOCIAL SERVICES.
MEANWHILE, THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION BUDGET IS NOW $19
BILLION. THE COST FOR EACH
PERSON WE KEEP IN PRISON IS
$130,000 A YEAR. THE COST PER
PERSON ARE SO HIGH IN PART
BECAUSE WE ARE PAYING FOR SO
MANY EMPTY BEDS. 13,000 BY LAST
COUNT. YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE THING
TO CUT EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES IN
ORDER TO PAY FOR THE NECESSARY
COSTS OF MAINTAINING OUR PRISON
SYSTEM. IT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THING TO CUT THE CORE
SERVICES THAT MOST CALIFORNIANS
RELY ON TO PAY FOR EMPTY PRISON
BEDS IS AB 12178 IS A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE BILL THAT MOVES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAREFULLY IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION, ENSURING
THAT WE CAN PROTECT THE SERVICES
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS RELY ON
FOR OUR EDUCATION, IN OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OUR SOCIAL NET
SERVICES. THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS, AND
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN AS A PRIMARY WITNESS?
IF NOT, WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
. IF THERE'S ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AS A
PRIMARY WITNESS, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
MATTHEW EASLEY, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION, WE DO
APPRECIATE THE MOTIVATIONS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL AB 2178, BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
USING ONLY BED VACANCIES AS THE
MEANS AND CALCULATION FOR
REDUCING CAPACITY. WHILE WE'RE
STILL OPERATING AT APPROXIMATELY
120% OF DESIGN CAPACITY. SO ONLY
INCREASING THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO ADDRESS FOR
OVER A DECADE. THE CLOSURES THAT
WILL NECESSARILY RESULT FROM
THIS BILL WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE AVAILABILITY OF PROGRAMING
SPACE. WHILE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS,
EDUCATION, CAREER, TECHNICAL,
SCHOOLING, GED PROGRAMS ARE
ALREADY COMPETING FOR SCARCE
SPACE IN PRISON. AND THIS IS
ONLY GOING TO FURTHER THAT
PROBLEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND IF THERE'S NO
OTHER LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES,
WE WILL TAKE THE METOOS. PLEASE
COME TO THE MIC, STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
REPRESENT, AND YOUR EITHER
APPROVAL OR DISAPPROVAL OF THE
MEASURE. DANICA ADAMO, ON BEHALF
OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND ELLA
BAKER CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EXCUSE ME, JIM LINDBERG, FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DAX PROCTOR, CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IN STRONG
SUPPORT. GEORGE TH¤U, ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA. ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DAN MESNER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. ED LITTLE, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MARLENA MERCADO WITH UNCOMMON
LAW AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE COMING TO SPEAK. DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY FROM THE DÍAS?
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS NOW. SENATOR SKINNER,
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE,
THE GOOD WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN DOING FOR
SOME NUMBER OF YEARS TO, TO
ADDRESS APPROPRIATE SENTENCING
SO THAT WE ARE USING OUR
CRIMINAL LAWS IN A WAY THAT, IN
FACT, PROTECTS PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT'S GOT TO BE OUR NUMBER ONE
OBJECTIVE, BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
BE SMART ABOUT OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR TAXPAYERS,
FOR THE BUDGET AS A WHOLE. AND
WITH THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
OVER THE LAST TEN, 15 YEARS, AS
YOU RIGHTLY POINTED OUT IN YOUR,
PRESENTATION, WE NOW HAVE A
PRISON POPULATION OF AROUND
90,000, AND YET WE HAVE
FACILITIES THAT WERE DESIGNED
FOR FAR MORE AT AND WE TO KEEP
YARDS OPEN THAT WHERE THERE'S
PERHAPS, YOU KNOW, TWO
INDIVIDUAL INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OR NONE IN, YOU
KNOW, COUNTLESS NUMBERS OF
FACILITIES IS NOT A GOOD USE OF
TAXPAYER FUNDS AND DOES NOT
PROMOTE PUBLIC SAFETY. IT ALSO
TIES UP MONEY THAT BECAUSE THIS
IS ONE OF OUR FEW AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE DISCRETION, AND THAT'S
MEANING THE CDCR'S BUDGET, IT
IS, IS ONE THAT IS A
DISCRETIONARY PART OF OUR
GENERAL FUND. THE FUNDS THAT WE
ARE, UTILIZING TO MAINTAIN BEDS
THAT WE DON'T NEED ARE FUNDS
THAT INSTEAD COULD BE USED FOR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. SO,
THERE'S JUST, SO MANY ASPECTS TO
WHY WE NEED TO RIGHTSIZE OUR
FACILITIES AND RIGHTSIZE OUR
CORRECTIONS BUDGET WHILE STILL
PUTTING PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST,
WHICH I THINK IS WHAT YOUR BILL
IS DOING. SO I'M APPRECIATIVE
THAT YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD.
HAPPY TO, MOVE IT. I HAVE SOME
ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THE LEO'S
WORK ON DOING THIS ANALYSIS TO
HELP US WITH THE DETERMINATION
OF WHAT IS AN APPROPRIATE,
CUSHION OR OR BED THRESHOLD TO
USE TO. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SIERRA. SO I HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING THE WHAT THE GOAL IS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST TO COUNT
BEDS AND THEN DECIDE THAT WE
HAVE INOPERABLE. YOU KNOW, WE
DON'T IT DOESN'T COST ANYTHING
TO HAVE AN EMPTY BED UNLESS
YOU'RE MAINTAINING A WHOLE
FACILITY THAT DOES THAT EMPTY,
YOU KNOW, THAT HOUSES THAT EMPTY
BED. SO THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A
WAY TO, TRY TO CONSOLIDATE THE
FACILITIES THAT WE DO HAVE
REMAINING BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN A
LOT OFFLINE. AND THOSE ARE HARD
TO FIRE BACK UP. WE HAVE THEM
KIND OF ON A ON A WARM, WARM
START STATUS RIGHT NOW, IS THAT
WHAT THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS,
IS TO TRY TO IDENTIFY MORE
PLACES WHERE WE CAN SHUT DOWN
MORE PRISONS OR DETERMINING
FACTOR IN SHUTTING DOWN THOSE
PRISONS. SO THIS BILL IS, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, FROM A REAL
ESTATE POINT OF VIEW, THAT IF
YOU HAVE EMPTY OFFICE BUILDINGS
PER SE, YOU'RE LOOKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE CONSOLIDATING
AND LOOKING AT HAVING THOSE
EMPTY OFFICE BUILDINGS, EITHER
TAKEN OFFLINE OR POTENTIALLY NOT
USED, OR YOU FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BETTER USE YOUR REAL ESTATE. I
THINK THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN,
SAY, AN OFFICE BUILDING AND A
PRISON IS THE FACT THAT YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE SIGNIFICANT,
STAFFING COSTS AND YOU HAVE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO KEEP IT UP.
AND SO WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS GIVEN
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
ANOTHER NUMBER OF EMPTY BEDS,
THIS IS ABOUT FORCING THE
DEPARTMENT TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
LONG TERM PLAN, A LONG TERM
VISION AROUND HOW TO BEST USE
ALL THEIR FACILITIES. I KNOW
THAT MYSELF, SENATOR SKINNER, A
NUMBER OF YEARS DURING BUDGET
HEARINGS HAVE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT FOR PLANS ON HOW THEY
PLAN TO USE THEIR FACILITIES,
GIVEN THAT THE POPULATION HAS
REALLY DROPPED IN HALF. AND SO
WHEN WE START, WHEN I STARTED IN
THE LEGISLATURE IN 2012, THE
PRISON POPULATION IS NOW HALF OF
WHAT THAT WAS IN 2012. AT THE
SAME TIME, THE BUDGET HAS GONE
UP ALMOST DOUBLE FROM WHEN IT
WAS IN 2012. NO OTHER, NO OTHER
DEPARTMENT, NO OTHER PROGRAM
WOULD WE FUND THIS WAY WE
WOULDN'T FUND CALWORKS THIS WAY
WE WOULDN'T FUND MEDI-CAL THIS
WAY WE WOULDN'T FUND UC OR CSU
OR ANY OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THIS WAY. AND SO IT'S REALLY
ASKING THE DEPARTMENT TO BE
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE. THIS IS
ONE METRIC. AND IF THEY HAD
OTHER METRICS, WE I'M HAPPY TO
INCORPORATE THEM IN THE BILL.
THEY HAVE NOT BROUGHT THAT
FORWARD, YOU HEARD OPPOSITION,
MENTIONED REHABILITATION THÀNH,
WHICH IS ALSO WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT MENTIONED IN BUDGET
HEARINGS, WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
WHEN I ASKED THEM WHAT
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THEY DO
IN PRISON CELLS, THEY COULDN'T
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. THEY THEY
SAID THEY ACTUALLY DON'T DO ANY
REHABILITATION IN PRISON CELLS.
SO IT'S KIND OF ODD THAT THEY
WOULD NEED THE EMPTY PRISON
CELLS FOR REHABILITATION. SO
AGAIN, IT'S SORT OF, BEEN VERY,
VERY FRUSTRATING IN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT THAT WE DON'T GET
ANSWERS. THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF
MONEY. AND THEY ABSOLUTELY HAVE
NO PLAN IN TERMS OF EITHER THEIR
LONG TERM CAPITAL NEEDS OR IN
TERMS OF THEIR CURRENT CAPITAL
USAGE. SO THIS BILL, I BELIEVE,
IS A ONE SMALL STEP IN REALLY
FORCING THE DEPARTMENT TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE. OKAY. WELL, THE
PRISONS THAT I VISITED AND SOME
OF THEM HAVE HAD THIS DECREASE
IN, IN POPULATION, HAVE EITHER
REPURPOSED THOSE, FACILITIES.
THE WHERE THE BEDS ARE, INTO, A,
A DIFFERENT, THING LIKE AN
EDUCATION HALL OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S A
USEFUL PURPOSE THAT THEY'RE
USING THEM FOR, OTHERWISE THEY
JUST SHUT OFF THE SWITCH AND,
AND IT'S EMPTY. AND THE
MAINTENANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR AN
EMPTY BUILDING THAT'S NOT USING
ELECTRICITY OR ANYTHING ELSE IS
NOT THAT MUCH. BUT WHAT IT DOES
PROVIDE IS FLEXIBILITY. AND THE
FLEXIBILITY COMES BECAUSE AS WE
HAVE ALLOWED OUR PRISON
POPULATION, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY
CELEBRATING, WE'VE ALLOWED THE
PRISON POPULATION TO GO IN HALF.
WELL, THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WE TOOK A BUNCH OF
THINGS THAT WERE CRIMES WHERE
PEOPLE USED TO GO TO PRISON FOR
AND THEY DON'T GO ANYMORE. AND,
AND SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY IS THAT
AN INDICATION THAT THERE'S LESS
CRIME, MAYBE A LITTLE BIT, I
DON'T KNOW, BUT WHAT I DO SEE IS
A BUNCH OF RETAIL THEFT BILL
PACKAGES THAT WERE NOW PROMOTING
AND A PROPOSITION ON A BALLOT
THAT HAS DECIDED THAT THAT WAS A
FAILED EXPERIMENT. AND THERE ARE
GOING TO BE PROBABLY MORE
ARRESTS, AROUND THIS. AND SO, I
THINK COUNTING BEDS AND THEN
SHUTTING DOWN PRISONS BECAUSE WE
HAVE SOME EMPTY BEDS, THE BEDS
DON'T TAKE ANYTHING TO MAINTAIN.
THERE'S NOBODY SHINING THEM UP
EVERY DAY OR HAVING TO MAKE THEM
EVERY DAY, SO, I'M THINKING THAT
OUR PRISON SYSTEM, IF YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST, WELL,
LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENT,
CITY AGENCY, GOVERNMENT AGENCY,
THE STATE, AND SEE WHO ELSE HAS
DOUBLED THEIR BUDGET SINCE 2012.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WE HAVE. SO
YEAH, THAT'S EVERYBODY. AND
THERE'S SO MANY COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT AND SO MANY REASONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. I'M KIND
OF TIRED OF HEARING THAT THEY'RE
THE ONLY ONES, SOMEHOW THAT HAVE
INCREASED THEIR BUDGET WHILE
THEY'RE DECREASING SOME
SERVICES, BECAUSE THEY'RE ON
STANDBY. STANDBY COSTS MONEY. WE
CAN'T JUST ELIMINATE THEM AS
MUCH AS SOME PEOPLE WOULD LOVE
TO DO THAT, SO, I THINK WHATEVER
WE'VE BEEN DOING IS PROBABLY
EXCESSIVE, WE'RE SHUTTING DOWN
YET ANOTHER PRISON. CHUCKAWALLA
AND, AND SO, YOU KNOW, WE'LL
HAVE ANOTHER DORMANT FACILITY,
IF YOU WANT TO FIX THE PRISON
SYSTEM, THEN FIX THE PRISON
SYSTEM. BUT IF WE JUST WANT TO
ELIMINATE FACILITIES SO WE CAN
SAY WE DON'T HAVE ROOM FOR
PEOPLE, I THINK THAT'S A
TERRIBLE WAY TO KEEP OUR PUBLIC
SAFE AND SO I WILL BE OPPOSING
THIS BILL TODAY, BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK IT IS HELPFUL FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE LONG RUN. AND I
THINK, HAVING THOSE BEDS
AVAILABLE ALLOWS US TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY WE NEED TO NOT JUST
MAKE CRIMES, NOT CRIMES ANYMORE,
BUT TO HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
AND SEPARATE PEOPLE WHEN WE NEED
TO, FROM THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
ARE, VICTIMIZING OUT THERE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE OTHER
PART OF, OF WHAT THIS SYSTEM IS
FOR, IT'S TO KEEP PEOPLE WHO
LIKE TO VICTIMIZE PEOPLE
SEPARATED FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST LAW ABIDING CITIZENS TRYING
TO GO ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS EVERY
DAY. SO, WITH THAT, I APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWERS. AND I'M NOT MOVING
THE BILL. I THINK IT WAS MOVED
BY SKINNER. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO JUST CLOSE, SURE. HAPPY
TO AGAIN. YOU KNOW, DURING TOUGH
FISCAL TIMES, WE HAVE TO MAKE
TOUGH FISCAL CHOICES. THIS ONE'S
A FAIRLY EASY ONE, THE
EQUIVALENCY OF 13,000 EMPTY BEDS
IS BETWEEN 3 TO 5 EMPTY PRISONS,
LAOS, THÀNH OF 20,000 EMPTY
BEDS, GETS US CLOSE TO 6 TO 7
EMPTY PRISONS, AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT CLOSING
SCHOOLS, SENDING LESS MONEY TO
UC AND CSU, PUTTING LESS FOOD ON
PEOPLE'S TABLES OR FINDING WAYS
THAT WE CAN FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS CHOICE IS EASY.
AND SO, AGAIN, I BELIEVE THIS IS
A FISCALLY PRUDENT BILL. I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THEY'D
BE 2178. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER. CAN
WE GET A ROLL CALL, PLEASE? ITEM
NUMBER TEN, AB 2178. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE'LL HAVE A JOB. I CIERTO.
SATO. NO. BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE WIENER THAT BILLS
ON CALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT AB 2483? I
WOULD, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
SO AB 2483 FOLLOWS THE
COMMISSION ON THE REVIEW OF THE
PENAL CODE'S RECOMMENDATION TO
SET STATEWIDE GUIDELINES
ENSURING EFFICIENT AND EQUITABLE
SENTENCING PROCEDURES. WE'VE
DONE OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS, A NUMBER OF RESENTENCING
PROCEDURE BILLS, INCLUDING A FEW
THAT I'VE DONE MYSELF. SO NOW
THAT WE HAVE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS,
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS, CDC,
OUR SECRETARY AND JUDGES, THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO REFER
PEOPLE BACK FOR A SECOND LOOK ON
THEIR SENTENCE. THIS BILL WOULD
JUST GIVE THE COURTS
STANDARDIZED GUIDELINES,
CREATING CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
STATE WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF RE
SENTENCING LAWS. I HAVE, TOM,
NOSOWITZ WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THE REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
AS A WITNESS. THANK YOU. AND YOU
ONLY HAVE ONE WITNESS. YES. ALL
RIGHT. YOU WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS. STAFF. I'M TOM
NORTHWOODS, LEGAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE COMMITTEE ON REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE, WHICH IS A STATE
ENTITY THAT WAS CREATED TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ALL ASPECTS OF
CRIMINAL LAW IN THE STATE. AS
MISTER TING SAID, THIS BILL IS
BASED ON A RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE PENAL CODE COMMITTEE'S MOST
RECENT ANNUAL REPORT, WE FOUND
THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S BEEN A
THE LEGISLATURE AND VOTER
INITIATIVES HAVE REGULARLY
CREATED RESENTENCING LAWS. BUT
EACH TIME THERE'S A NEW LAW,
THERE MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
PROCEDURES OR CERTAIN PROCEDURES
ARE NOT ADDRESSED. AND IT WASTES
A LOT OF TIME IN COURT WITH
PARTIES AND THE JUDGES. AND THEN
THERE'S APPELLATE LITIGATION TO
WORK THESE THINGS OUT, WHICH IS
A YOU KNOW, AVOIDS GETTING TO
THE HEART OF WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN IS WHETHER SOMEONE SHOULD
GET A NEW SENTENCE OR NOT. SO
THE RULES THAT ARE IN THIS BILL
ARE DEFAULTS. IF THERE'S
SOMETHING IN A RESENTENCING
PROVISION THAT'S MORE SPECIFIC,
THAT WOULD CONTROL IF THERE'S A
NEW RESENTENCING LAW THAT COULD,
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT PROCEDURAL
RULE WITH THAT NEW LAW. AND WE
FOUND THESE RULES BY LOOKING AT
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
AND RECENT BILLS, WHAT COURTS
HAVE DECIDED AND WHAT
PRACTITIONERS TOLD US WOULD BE
MOST EFFICIENT. AND THE BILL
ALSO DIRECTS CDCR, THE PRISON
AUTHORITY, TO MAKE RECORDS
AVAILABLE MORE READILY, WHICH IS
OFTEN A BIG DELAY IN GETTING
THESE RE SENTENCINGS DONE. SO
THIS BILLS, THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE COURT
PROCEEDINGS MORE EFFICIENT AND
FOCUSED ON THE MERITS OF WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN IN A RESENTENCING
AND NOT DISTRACTED BY COLLATERAL
OR PROCEDURAL ISSUES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CAN WE HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION? MY NAME IS KRISTEN
SCHLUSSEL. I'M A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY,
AND I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION TO URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL 2483, WHICH
WILL CREATE GREATER
INCONSISTENCY AND INEFFICIENCIES
IN POST-CONVICTION PROCEDURES.
AB 2483 HAS THE POTENTIAL FOR
CREATING AMBIGUITY AND
UNCERTAINTY IN THESE
POST-CONVICTION MATTERS BY
SEEKING TO IMPOSE A GENERALIZED
FRAMEWORK FOR THE FORM, PROCESS,
TIME OF PETITIONS, AND
ELIGIBILITY FOR RELIEF UNDER
VARIOUS AMELIORATIVE STATUTES.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE ALREADY
DISTINCT MECHANISMS IN PLACE FOR
INITIATING AND OBTAINING RELIEF
UNDER THESE STATUTES BY
ATTEMPTING TO ENCOMPASS ALL
PROCEEDINGS TO MODIFY A SENTENCE
OR CONVICTION PURSUANT TO AN
AMELIORATIVE STATUTE, WITHOUT
CLEARLY DEFINING THE SCOPE, AB
2483 OPENS THE DOOR TO CONFUSION
AND EXTENSIVE LITIGATION IN THE
PROVISION GRANTING COURTS
JURISDICTION TO CONSIDER ANY
PERTINENT CIRCUMSTANCES TO
MODIFY EVERY ASPECT OF A
SENTENCE COULD POTENTIALLY LEAD
TO LIMITLESS AUTHORITY TO ALTER
A SENTENCE. DESPITE A JURY'S
UNANIMOUS VERDICT OR A PLEA
AGREEMENT, THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
EVERY PART OF A LAWFULLY
OBTAINED JUDGMENT IS SUBJECT TO
BEING STRUCK, DISMISSED, OR
MODIFIED, CREATING FURTHER LEGAL
UNCERTAINTY FOR ALL PARTIES,
INCLUDING CRIME VICTIMS.
MOREOVER, THE RETROACTIVE
APPLICATION OF 2483 RAISES
CONCERNS ABOUT ITS IMPACT ON
PAST CONVICTIONS AND SENTENCES
WITHOUT CLEAR GUIDANCE ON HOW
THE BILL APPLIES RETROACTIVELY,
THERE IS A RISK OF DISRUPTING
SUBTLE JUDGMENTS AND CREATING
ADDITIONAL LEGAL CHALLENGES FOR
BOTH PROSECUTORS AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS. THEREFORE, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
AB 2483. THANK YOU. CAN WE GET
ME TOOS BOTH IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION, PLEASE CLEARLY STATE
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
NATASHA MINSKER SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
NICODERM ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND
ALSO DELIVERING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ELLA BAKER CENTER. AND
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MARGIE LEE SAMSON,
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF FAMILIES
AGAINST MANDATORY MINIMUMS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. JIM LINDBERG,
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT GEORGE
TH¤U ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. DAN MESNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CECILIA CHÁVEZ, ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, WOULD YOU GUYS LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THE ITEM SEEING
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, AGAIN, THIS IS A
FAIRLY SIMPLE BILL THAT THE
COMMITTEE ON THE REVISION OF THE
PENAL CODE, I THINK, WENT
THROUGH JUST TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS, MAKE IT
SIMPLER, AND MORE EFFICIENT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
2483. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? DO WE HAVE A MOTION? SO
MOVED. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SKINNER MOVES THE BILL, LET'S
GET A ROLL CALL. VOTE ITEM
NUMBER 11, AB 2483. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WILL
HAVE I, I. SEYARTO SATO. NOT
VOTING BRADFORD. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. WIENER THAT BILLS
ON CALL. THANK YOU. SOME MEMBER.
COULD DO WITH CALLS WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR CALLERS.
ON FILE. ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB
1831 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
CAN I GET A MOTION? YES. SO
MOVED. SENATOR SATO HAS MOVED
THE BILL. CAN WE GET A ROLL CALL
? ITEM NUMBER THREE, 1831.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I HAVE
AYE. SATO. SATO AYE. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WIENER
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILLS ON CALL.
CAN WE ALSO GET A ROLL CALL FOR
ITEM NUMBER SIX? AB 1874 BY
SANCHEZ. ITEM NUMBER SIX, 1874.
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB. HI.
WAHAB. I BRADFORD. SATO. AYE.
SEYARTO SKINNER. SORRY. YEAH.
OH. NOT VOTING OKAY, I
APOLOGIZE. WIENER. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILLS ON CALL. CAN WE GET,
DO YOU WANT US TO START FROM THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE SKINNER WAS.
NO, I WANT TO DO MINES FIRST,
FINAL ITEM, NUMBER SEVEN, AB
1877 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON,
1877. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB I, WAHAB I
BRADFORD, WIENER. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 13 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SORIA. AB 2281. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE 2 TO 0. WAHAB I HAVE I
BRADFORD WIENER. ALL RIGHT. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. AND CAN WE GET
A FILE NUMBER 16 AB 2519 BY
MAIENSCHEIN. MOTION ITEM 16
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS 2 TO 0. CURRENT
VOTE. WAHAB AYE, AYE. BRADFORD.
SKINNER. ALL RIGHT, BRADFORD.
WIENER. AM I DOING? LET'S DO IT
AGAIN. FILE ITEM NUMBER 16, AB
2519 BY MAIENSCHEIN. CORRECT
BRADFORD WIENER. THANK YOU. THAT
FILE ITEM IS STILL ON CALL.
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, WILL
BE PRESENTING FILE ITEM 20 AB
3021. AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. I CAN'T
HEAR YOU. I'M SORRY. WHAT'S SHE
SAYING? WE NEED TO OPEN THE
ROLES ON THE. YEAH, YEAH. NO.
WE'RE DONE. THANK. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS AB 3021
REQUIRES PEACE OFFICERS
PROSECUTING ATTORNEYS OR
INVESTIGATORS TO IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES AND EXPLAIN THE RIGHT
OF INDIVIDUALS BEING QUESTIONED
PRIOR TO ENGAGING WITH THE
IMMEDIATE FAMILY OF SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN KILLED OR SEVERELY
INJURED BY A PEACE OFFICER IN
THE AFTERMATH OF INCIDENTS
INVOLVING POLICE VIOLENCE,
FAMILIES OF THE VICTIM ARE OFTEN
APPROACHED BY AUTHORITIES UNDER
THE GUISE OF AN INTERVIEW.
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE TOLD TO GO TO
THE PRECINCT, NOT GIVEN
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STATE OF
THEIR LOVED ONE, AND OFTEN LIED
TO ABOUT THE INCIDENT AS THEY
ARE INTERROGATED. WHILE THE
FAMILY MEMBER IS DISTRESSED AND
WORRIED FOR THEIR LOVED ONE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COERCE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE VICTIM'S
PAST IN ORDER TO INCRIMINATE THE
DECEASED AND SHIELD OFFICERS
FROM LIABILITY. INITIALLY
INITIALLY PERCEIVED BY FAMILIES
AS ISOLATED INCIDENTS, IT HAS
COME TO LIGHT THAT THIS PRACTICE
IS A POLICE INTERROGATION TACTIC
PROMOTED BY A PRIVATE ENTITY
NAMED LEXIPOL. LEXAPOL OFFERS
INSTRUCTION ON 95% OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ON
TECHNIQUES TO EXTRACT
INFORMATION FROM FAMILIES, WITH
THE AIM OF PROTECTING OFFICERS
FROM LEGAL REPERCUSSIONS AND
CRIMINAL ALLEGATIONS, SUCH
TACTICS NOT ONLY INFLICT A HARM
UPON THE VICTIM AND THEIR FAMILY
, BUT ALSO ERODE TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FAMILY MEMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED BY POLICE
VIOLENCE HAVE A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION OF TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THEIR LOVED ONES,
WITHOUT BEING MANIPULATED BY
PUTTING IN A FEW MOMENTS BETWEEN
THE INCIDENT AND INTERROGATION,
THEN WE CAN EMPOWER FAMILIES TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS IN
INTERACTIONS WITH POLICE
OFFICERS WHEN THEY ARE MOST
VULNERABLE. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS SAM
SULLIVAN, SISTER OF DAVID
SULLIVAN AND ED LITTLE WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. SO EACH WITNESS WILL
GET TWO MINUTES. GO AHEAD. YOU.
YOU CAN START. MY NAME IS SAM
SULLIVAN. MY LITTLE BROTHER,
DAVID SULLIVAN, WAS MURDERED ON
THE MORNING OF AUGUST 19TH,
2019, BY BUENA PARK POLICE
OFFICERS BOBBY COLON AND
JENNIFER TRAN. I WAS INFORMED OF
HIS DEATH AROUND 1 A.M. THAT
NIGHT AND WITH NO SLEEP OR
INFORMATION, WE WERE ASKED TO
SPEAK WITH THE DA'S DEPUTIES. I
BELIEVE THEY WERE INVESTIGATING
THE WRONGFUL ACTIONS OF THE
OFFICERS WHO KILLED DAVID.
INSTEAD, THEY HAD A PLAN TO
EXTRAPOLATE INFORMATION ABOUT
DAVID TO PROVE HIS KILLING WAS
JUSTIFIED, AND TO FIT A
STANDARDIZED NARRATIVE OF
SUICIDE BY COP. THESE TACTICS,
IMPLEMENTED BY CONTROVERSIAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICY PROVIDER
LEXIPOL, TURNS OUR GRIEVING
RAMBLINGS INTO EVIDENCE AGAINST
OUR LOVED ONES. DURING THIS
INTERROGATION, I WAS ASKED
LEADING QUESTIONS WITH NO
RELEVANCE ABOUT MY BROTHER'S
MENTAL HEALTH. HIS POPULARITY IN
SCHOOL, EVEN HIS FEELINGS ABOUT
BEING OVERWEIGHT. DAVID WAS
UNARMED, BUT THEY ASKED
REPEATEDLY IF HE HAD A GUN.
THEIR GOAL WAS TO GET ONE PERSON
TO CONFIRM THEIR NARRATIVE OF
DAVID BEING DEPRESSED AND
SUICIDAL. I'M ASHAMED TO SAY I
FELL DIRECTLY INTO THIS TRAP AND
CONFIRMED THEIR SPECULATIONS.
WITHOUT QUESTION. I WAS WILLING
TO ACCEPT THEIR VERSION OF
REALITY UNDER THIS MOMENT OF
DURESS, BECAUSE MY REALITY HAD
BEEN SHATTERED. A LARGE FOCUS OF
THE DEFENSE'S CASE WAS IN
REFERENCE TO MY INTERVIEW,
CLAIMING I CONFIRMED DAVID'S
SUICIDAL INTENT. BRUCE PRATT,
THE DEFENSE LAWYER FOR BUENA
PARK AND CO-FOUNDER OF LEXIPOL,
WAS ABLE TO PICK AND CHOOSE MY
WORDS TO FIT HIS FABRICATION OF
WHO DAVID WAS IN AN ATTEMPT TO
CONVINCE THE JURY THAT DAVID WAS
GOING TO DIE THAT DAY,
REGARDLESS OF THE NEGLIGENT
ACTIONS OF THOSE OFFICERS. AB
3021 IS AIMED TO BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY TO AN OVERSIGHT
IN THE CURRENT LEGAL SYSTEM.
POLICE VICTIMS FAMILIES DESERVE
HONESTY, SUPPORT AND EQUAL
RIGHTS AS THE PERPETRATING
OFFICERS WHO GET PAID LEAVE,
LEGAL CONSULTATION AND THE
ABILITY TO REVIEW BODY CAM
FOOTAGE PRIOR TO GIVING A
STATEMENT. HAD THIS BILL BEEN IN
PLACE THE DAY DAVID WAS KILLED,
OUR FAMILY LIKELY WOULD NOT HAVE
AGREED TO SPEAK WITH THE DA'S
OFFICE RIGHT AWAY AND TAKEN A
MOMENT TO PROCESS RATHER THAN
GIVING THEM FURTHER AMMUNITION
TO ASSASSINATE DAVID'S CHARACTER
AS POLICE KILLINGS CONTINUE TO
RISE, THE NEED FOR VICTIMS
FAMILIES TO BE INFORMED OF THEIR
RIGHTS GROWS. AND ON OUR ON
THEIR BEHALF. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 3021. THANK YOU, CAN
WE GET THE NEXT LEAD WITNESS?
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR WAHAB AND
SENATORS, MY NAME IS ED LITTLE
AND I'M A GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. FAMILY
MEMBERS OF VICTIMS WHO HAVE BEEN
SERIOUSLY INJURED OR KILLED
DESERVE INFORMATION AND SUPPORT,
NOT MANIPULATION, COERCION.
REGARDLESS OF WHO CAUSED THE
HARM. BUT IN CALIFORNIA, MANY
SURVIVORS WHOSE FAMILY MEMBERS
ARE INJURED OR KILLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE NOT GIVEN THIS
BASIC DIGNITY. THEY ARE INSTEAD
TOO OFTEN DENIED INFORMATION,
MANIPULATED INTO SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR LOVED
ONES PAST WHILE WORRIED AND NOT
KNOWING IF THEIR FAMILY MEMBER
IS SAFE. THIS PRACTICE IS NOT AN
ACCIDENT, AND LA TIMES
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE TRAINED TO
WITHHOLD INFORMATION FROM
WORRIED FAMILY MEMBERS OF
VICTIMS IN ORDER TO EXTRACT
INFORMATION TO MAKE A CASE
AGAINST THE VICTIM WHO HAS BEEN
SERIOUSLY INJURED OR KILLED.
OFFICERS MAY GIVE FAMILY MEMBERS
THE IMPRESSION THAT THEIR LOVED
ONE HAS BEEN ARRESTED OR ACCUSED
OF A CRIME, AND FAMILY MEMBERS
MAY VOLUNTEER INFORMATION THAT
THEY THINK WILL HELP, NOT
KNOWING THAT THEIR LOVED ONE HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN KILLED. THESE
PRACTICES COMPOUND TRAUMA AND
FRACTURED TRUST. WHEN FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE FINALLY GIVEN THE
DEVASTATING NEWS, NO ONE SHOULD
BE TREATED THIS WAY IN THEIR
MOMENTS OF DEEPEST PAIN AND
VULNERABILITY. AB 3021 PROVIDES
BASIC PROTECTIONS FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS OF VICTIMS OF POLICE
VIOLENCE AND CLARITY FOR
OFFICERS ON HOW TO ADVISE FAMILY
MEMBERS OF THEIR RIGHTS. THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE OFFICERS TO
CLEARLY IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND
TO ADVISE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
VICTIMS SERIOUSLY INJURED OR
KILLED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
THEIR RIGHTS, INCLUDING THE
RIGHT TO ASK FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
WELL-BEING, TO REFUSE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS, TO SPEAK TO AN
ATTORNEY ADVOCATE, OR SUPPORT
PERSON FIRST. FOR THESE REASONS,
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
3021. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CAN
I HAVE LEAD OPPOSITION? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CORY SALZILLO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION, THIS BILL CREATES
NEW RIGHTS FOR FAMILY MEMBERS OF
PERSONS KILLED OR SERIOUSLY
INJURED BY A PEACE OFFICER
CONFERRING THESE RIGHTS TO
FAMILY MEMBERS WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
IMPEDE INVESTIGATIONS AND COULD
HINDER LAW ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY
TO QUICKLY AND ACCURATELY
ASCERTAIN INFORMATION RELEVANT
AND VITAL TO AN INVESTIGATION.
AND THAT'S THE POINT OF THESE
INTERACTIVE ACTIONS. THE BILL,
DESPITE THE RECENT AMENDMENTS,
ALSO CONTINUES TO CREATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF SITUATIONS WHERE
A FAMILY MEMBER MAY BE KILLED OR
INJURED AND ANOTHER FAMILY
MEMBER MAY BE INVOLVED IN AN
ALLEGED CRIMINAL ACT. AND THIS
BILL FAILS TO ADEQUATELY ACCOUNT
FOR SUCH SITUATIONS AND COULD
CREATE UNTENABLE CIRCUMSTANCES,
INCLUDING A SCENARIO WHERE, BY
VIRTUE OF THE FACT THAT A PERSON
IS NOT BEING DETAINED, THEY'RE
TOLD THEY'RE NOT BEING DETAINED
FOR THE PURPOSES OF QUESTIONING
THEM ABOUT THEIR DECEASED OR
INJURED FAMILY MEMBER, BUT THEN
POTENTIALLY DETAINED LATER FOR
THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN THE
UNDERLYING ACT. AGAIN, THERE
HAVE BEEN AMENDMENTS, BUT WE
DON'T THINK THIS RECTIFIES THE
SITUATION, FINALLY, I WOULD JUST
SAY THE BILL CREATES A FALSE
EQUIVALENCY BETWEEN PERSONS WHO
ARE DETAINED FOR A CUSTODIAL
INTERROGATION AND THE RIGHTS
THAT THEY HAVE BY VIRTUE OF
THEIR DETENTION. AND 50 PLUS
YEARS OF SUPREME COURT
JURISPRUDENCE AND PERSONS WHO
HAPPEN TO BE RELATED TO SOMEONE
WHO IS KILLED OR INJURED BY A
PEACE OFFICER. AND WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE PROPONENTS DESIRE
HERE, BUT FEEL THIS BILL WILL
IMPEDE INVESTIGATIONS BY GIVING
CERTAIN PEOPLE RIGHTS TO WHICH
THEY ARE NOT CURRENTLY ENTITLED.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YOU'LL
HAVE TWO MINUTES AS WELL. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS KRISTEN
SCHLUSSEL. I'M A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AT THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE, AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB 3021, WHICH
IMPOSES MIRANDA LIKE WARNINGS ON
NON-CUSTODIAL POLICE ENCOUNTERS.
MIRANDA WARNINGS ARE RESERVED
FOR CUSTODIAL INTERROGATIONS,
WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE SUSPECTED
OF CRIMES. BECAUSE SUCH
SITUATIONS ARE INHERENTLY
COERCIVE, AND THE WARNINGS ARE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT A SUSPECT'S
RIGHT AGAINST
SELF-INCRIMINATION. FAMILY
MEMBERS AFFECTED BY POLICE
INCIDENTS ARE NOT SUSPECTS, NOR
ARE THEY IN CUSTODY, PROVIDING
MIRANDA LIKE WARNINGS TO ANYONE
OTHER THAN AN ACCUSED WOULD
CONFUSE AND CHEAPEN A SYSTEM
THAT HAS SPENT DECADES TRYING TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS TO
THOSE WHO ARE ACCUSED OF
COMMITTING CRIMES. THE CORE
ISSUE LIES IN THE POTENTIAL FOR
THESE WARNINGS TO MISLEAD RATHER
THAN INFORM, TELLING A FAMILY
FAMILY MEMBER THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT. THAT
ANYTHING THEY CAN SAY, ANYTHING
THEY SAY CAN BE USED AGAINST
THEM IN COURT, THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO REFUSE TO BE
SEARCHED, AND THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO LEGAL REPRESENTATION,
COULD CARRY AN IMPLICATION OF
GUILT, AS MIRANDA RIGHTS ARE
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS
SELF-INCRIMINATE ATION. AS SUCH,
FAMILY MEMBERS MAY USE THESE MAY
VIEW THESE WARNINGS AS
INHERENTLY ACCUSATORY. APPLYING
THESE WARNINGS TO NON SUSPECTS
COULD DETER INDIVIDUALS FROM
PROVIDING CRUCIAL INFORMATION IN
A SITUATION WHERE UNDERSTANDING
THE WHOLE PICTURE, LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH HISTORY, IS VITAL.
MOREOVER, THIS BILL WOULD
OBSTRUCT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
FAMILIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT,
HINDERING THE PURSUIT OF JUSTICE
AND TRANSPARENCY. FAMILIES PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN PROVIDING
CONTEXT AND UNDERSTANDING IN
SUCH SENSITIVE CASES, WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL FOR FAIR AND INFORMED
DECISION MAKING. THEREFORE, WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
ASSEMBLY BILL 3021. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. CAN WE GET ME TWOS
BOTH IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
AGAIN, STATE YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE NOTHING ELSE.
THANK YOU. DANICA DARNELL, ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. JONATHAN
FELDMAN, CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING, GLENN BACCHUS, FOR
THE ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT. NATASHA
MINSKER SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT GEORGE
FRAMPTON ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, DAX PROCTOR
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND SUPPORT.
DAN MESNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MARLENA MERCADO
WITH UNCOMMON LAW AND STRONG
SUPPORT. JIM LINDBERG, FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. SHARON
WATKINS IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZER FOR
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG. STRONG
SUPPORT. DEANNA SULLIVAN, MOTHER
OF DAVID SULLIVAN AND, ALSO WITH
DEBUG AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ANTHONY LOZANO IN SUPPORT OF THE
FAMILY OF DAVID SULLIVAN IN
SUPPORT. ROSIE CHÁVEZ WITH
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG ALSO
IMPACTED FAMILY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. JUDY EDENS, THE MOTHER
OF JASON ALDERMAN IN SUPPORT.
THERESA SMITH, MOTHER OF CESAR
CRUZ. AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. REGINA CARDENAS
IMPACTED FAMILY MEMBER. I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
MARIELENA VASQUEZ AND SUPPORT
FOR MY MICAH IS JENNIFER VASQUEZ
. JESSE. JESSE, FATHER OF
ANTHONY NUNEZ IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SANDY SANCHEZ, MOTHER OF 18 YEAR
OLD ANTHONY, KILLED 24TH OF
JULY, 2016, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JULIANNE SIGNS GREAT
GRANDDAUGHTER OF RUDY CARDENAS
IN SUPPORT. I'M INTERESTED IN
STATISTICS. CARDENAS
GRANDDAUGHTER OF JUDY CARDENAS
IN SUPPORT. IN STRONG SUPPORT,
THE PARENTS OF DIANA SHULMAN,
DAVID TOVAR, ANTHONY JUNIOR,
ANTHONY GUZMAN LOPEZ, TYLER
SCOTT RUSHING AND STEVEN TAYLOR
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG IN STRONG SUPPORT. RAYMOND
GOINS, SILICON VALLEY DEBUG ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILIES OF
FRANCISCO VILLARREAL, TREVOR
SEAVER, LORENZO CRUZ, ERNIE
SERRANO AND CRYSTAL OKAMOTO,
STRONGLY SUPPORT. SOME FAMILIES
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY THAT
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THE
FAMILY OF BRANDON ANTHONY LOPEZ,
DEMETRIUS STANLEY, FURMAN,
VINCENT VALENZUELA, AND I THINK
THAT'S IT. HERE HELLO, LIZ
GONZALEZ WITH SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG AND STRONG SUPPORT. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILIES THAT
COULDN'T BE HERE, THE FAMILY OF
JESUS MONTES, THE FAMILY OF
MICHAEL BARRERA, THE FAMILY OF
JAIME NARANJO. THE FAMILY OF
DARNELL BENSON. THE FAMILY OF
MICHAEL BARRON. THANK YOU.
SORRY. ONE MORE FAMILY IN
SUPPORT OF MIKE NELSON, JUNIOR.
A COUPLE MORE. THE FAMILY OF
AGUSTIN MORALES. THE FAMILY OF
RICHARD HAAPOJA AND THE FAMILY
OF AJ PHILLIPS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION. I
DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE FAMILIES
COMING HERE, ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE OF YOU GUYS THAT HAVE LOST
A LOVED ONE EVEN YEARS AGO. I
WILL SAY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THAT
IN MY CITY, WHEN I WAS A COUNCIL
MEMBER, WE DID HAVE AN
OFFICER-INVOLVED SHOOTING, AND,
YOU KNOW, IT OPENED MY EYES TO
HOW THINGS ARE DONE. AND, YOU
KNOW, THE FAMILY COMPLAINED THAT
THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THE TIME
OF DEATH OF THE INDIVIDUAL. THEY
WERE GIVEN 2 OR 3 DIFFERENT
TIMES, AND OBVIOUSLY, WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMES TO YOUR DOOR,
YOU'RE OFTEN SCARED AND YOU'RE
UNDER THE PRETENSE OF, I'M
TRYING TO HELP FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND SO FORTH. SO NOT
ALL INFORMATION IS VERY
TRANSPARENT. SO I DO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS IS A
DIFFICULT, SITUATION FOR A LOT
OF FAMILY MEMBERS. AND MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THEIR RIGHTS ARE IN GENERAL, AND
LET ALONE WHEN THEY ARE AWARE
THAT A LOVED ONE IS IN CRISIS,
YOU KNOW, THEY WANT TO DO
ANYTHING AND SAY ANYTHING TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT OF SOME
SORT, WITHOUT KNOWING THE FULL
CONTEXT OF THE SITUATION. SO I
DO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, MADAM
CHAIR, AND WE'LL TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS AS MY CLOSE APPRECIATE
IT AND I VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
SKINNER, ITEM NUMBER 2888 3021.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATE. WAHAB I HAVE I SEE
NO SATO. NO. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
WIENER. THANK YOU. THAT BILL IS
ON CALL. APPRECIATE IT. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BE. CAN WE
JUST ASK IF SENATOR WIENER IS
HERE PRESENTING IN JUDICIAL
RIGHT NOW? IS HE NOT DONE? NO,
HE'S NOT DONE. Þ WE CAN GO
THROUGH AND GET EVERYBODY ELSE
FOR NOW. I'VE BEEN HIS STAFF HAS
BEEN TELLING ME.
WE WILL BE LIFTING CALLS ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THROUGH CONSENT,
LET'S DO CONSENT. AND JUST MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS VOTED ON
CONSENT. CONSENT. CALENDAR.
SKINNER. I WIENER I WIENER. THAT
IS STILL ON CALL. WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB 852. MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ZERO.
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER NUMBER ONE.
SKINNER. AYE THAT BILLS ON CALL
NUMBER TWO. ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
2136 JONES-SAWYER ÁP. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1. SKINNER
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. THAT BILL IS
ON CALL NUMBER THREE. ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 1331. BERMAN.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 3 TO 0. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE ALL RIGHT. THAT BILLS ON
CALL NUMBER SIX. NUMBER SIX AB
1874. SANCHEZ. MOTION IS Dð PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 2 TO 0. BRADFORD. JUST SAY
SKINNER NOT VOTING CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT. OKAY. BRADFORD. I THAT
BILLS ON CALL NUMBER SEVEN. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB 1877 JACKSON.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. MOVING TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN. AB 2178 TING. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR.
VOTING NO. BRADFORD I BRADFORD I
THANK YOU. NUMBER 11. THAT BILL
IS ON CALL. SORRY SORRY. GO
AHEAD AB 2483. MOTION TING.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. THAT
BILL IS ON CALL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 13 AB 2281. SORIA MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
VICE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. BOTH
VOTING AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL IS ON
CALL NUMBER 15 2518. DAVIES.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. NOT VOTING. SKINNER.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 2519.
MAINTAIN CURRENT OR MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 0. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE NUMBER 18 AB 2645.
LACKEY. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION. CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. SKINNER AND
NUMBER 20. AYE. SKINNER. AYE THE
BILLS ON CALL NUMBER 20. OH,
WAIT. YEAH, I'LL DO ONE ON THAT
ONE. SO.
THIS IS NOT LIKE WE ARE WAITING
ON SENATOR WIENER. WE'RE HOPING
THAT HE ARRIVES SO WE CAN CLOSE
OUT THE ROLL, ESSENTIALLY WITH
OUR CHANGE. SO, FOLLOWING ON.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS, WE WILL START WITH
CONSENT ITEMS. AND THEN ALSO
JUST GET WORSE. PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL. ALL RIGHT. ON THE CONSENT
ITEMS, CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. CONSENT IS
OUT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. ALL RIGHT
AB 18 NÓ AB 852 JONES-SAWYER.
MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0. WIENER. Ã WIENER. AYE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO NUMBER TWO.
THAT'S THAT. THAT BILL IS OUT 5
TO 0. AB 2136 JONES-SAWYER
CURRENT MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO 3 TO 1.
WE'LL HAVE AYE COR. SO NÓ
WIENER. AYE. WIENER. AYE THAT
BILL IS OUT 4 TO 1 AB 1831
BERMAN. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0. WIENER
Ã WIENER. AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT
. AB 1874 SANCHEZ. MOTION IS DUE
. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 TO ZERO.
SKINNER WAS NOT VOTING WIENER
WIENER. AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT
1877 JACKSON MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR. VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING NO.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. THAT BILL IS
OUT. AB 2178 TING. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING
NO. WIENER. Ã. WIENER. AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT AB 2483 TING.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING VOTE.
NOT VOTING. WIENER. Ã. WIENER.
AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT. AB 2281
SORIA. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WIENER WIENER. AYE. THE
BILL IS OUT ÁP 2518. DAVIES.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0. BRADFORD. SKINNER NOT
VOTING WIENER WIENER. AYE. THAT
BILL IS OUT ÁP 25, 19
MAIENSCHEIN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0. WIENER Ã WIENER BILLS
OUT AB 2645. LACKEY MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO
0. WIENER WIENER. AYE. THAT BILL
IS OUT AB 3021 CALL MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1. CHAIR.
AYE. VICE CHAIR. NO WIENER. Ã.
WIENER. AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT
AND WE ARE DONE. THAT IS ALL.
THANK YOU. ALL. COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.